Patrick Bateman was born in October 1961
which we can calculate because he turns
27 in October 1988. in March 1966 when
Patrick was four years old his younger
brother Sean was born the two brothers
would not get along and were opposites
in many ways the Bateman family may have
lived somewhere in the South if we're
gonna believe what Sean tells his
college classmates then again he often
lies to them and tells them he's poor
plus neither brother has a Southern
accent they do however have a family
home in Newport which is in Rhode Island
their father's long-term hotel suite in
New York City and their grandfather's
home in Connecticut all of which are in
the Northeast United States Patrick was
studious and took after his father
eventually ending up at a job with
connections to his dad's circles Sean on
the other hand was a terrible student
and was more interested in a rock and
roll type of Lifestyle rock and roll
although they did not get along the two
participated in upscale activities
together like riding horses and playing
tennis with the two Bateman Brothers do
have in common is a natural charm with
women despite both being incredibly
sleazy in their dating lives in Sean's
case he's just an extremely selfish
conceited idiot Patrick on the other
hand has a better reputation but in
reality he is a complete raging
psychopath there are many elements that
make up Patrick Bateman's psychopathy so
many in fact that you could not fit them
all on one tape so I've collected each
of them and put them together to paint
the true picture of his character if you
want to hear about Patrick's life before
and after American Psycho the answer to
important questions like were his
killings real or imagined and which
parts of Patrick Bateman were inspired
from real life then stick around to the
end of this video
[Music]
welcome to Horror history the show where
I fully analyzed the minds and timelines
of characters and villains in the horror
genre my name is Marcus halberstam and
today I'll be covering the entire story
of Patrick bate Patrick is most known
from American Psycho the modern classic
by Brett Easton Ellis which was brought
to the screen in 2000 by director Mary
Hare however his first appearance
predates that in Ellis's 1987 novel The
Rules of Attraction as usual the books
are considered Canon so I'll be
analyzing Bateman's story from the page
Patrick is certainly one of the if not
the craziest characters I've ever
covered on Horror history his psychosis
becomes so bad that it can be impossible
to determine what's real and what's
hallucinatory when the story is being
told from his point of view one of the
most asked questions about American
Psycho is did Patrick Bateman kill
anyone not even the author himself knows
but it's the question that I am
constantly ask at every reading I give
and there's no answer to it because I
don't have an answer to it I didn't have
an answer when I was writing it I didn't
know I mean I thought it could go either
way you know I kept flips
once writing the book and that became to
me something very interesting however
after reading the book a couple times
and researching some other things the
author has said publicly I think I've
come up with a pretty satisfying answer
that being said it's still impossible to
determine what is and isn't taking place
in Bateman's imagination at times so as
a general rule just to make this video
possible I'll try to take Bateman's word
unless he gives us a reason to doubt him
which you'll find is quite often part of
my analysis in a typical episode of
Horror history is figuring out the
timeline of events exactly when did
everything take place while we have a
pretty good idea for most of the story
Patrick seems to lose track of time
towards the end so at a certain point
I'll have to use other means to
determine the dates rather than taking
his word for it but in order to get into
the mysteries of his character I'm going
to hit rewind and go back to the
formation of Patrick Bateman's Insanity
during his early teenage years
[Music]
Twas the Night Before Christmas
1975 when a young Patrick Bateman found
trouble
night he got a bit too frisky and wanted
to play and it came at the expense of
one of the maze
Patrick attended a school called Exeter
where he first met Christopher Armstrong
who would eventually work at his company
in their adulthood after this he
attended Harvard University in Cambridge
Massachusetts eventually transferring
into their business school this seems to
be about the time that his homicidal
thoughts and possibly actions took Roots
because nobody seems to know that he's a
psychopath it makes sense that this
tendency would develop once he's out on
his own where he would presumably have
some more privacy the earliest mentioned
kill he makes came during his junior
year at Harvard after a freshman girl
told him that life is full of endless
possibilities and he was so exasperated
that he decapitated her hung her head on
a tree and chucked her body into the
Charles whether his kills are real or
imaginary doesn't matter when discussing
the motivation behind them red East and
Ellis has written seven novels the first
of which was called less than zero which
is about the idea of passivity there's a
passive man in the culture is he really
the same one because of the insane chaos
that surrounds him or is he just as bad
as the insane chaos around him because
he doesn't ask taken at face value
American Psycho seems to be the exact
opposite an insane chaotic psychopath
living in the dull banality of corporate
Wall Street Life Ellis states that he
initially wrote the novel based on
feelings of loneliness and alienation
that he was having at the time he
considers most of his work to be fiction
inspired by aspects of his actual life
and he interestingly cites American
Psycho as his most autobiographical
novel I think it really became a book
about my problems with being a young man
with a lot of money in Manhattan you can
kind of Imagine Ellis sitting at a bar
and some dumb girl telling him life is
full of endless possibilities and he's
just so cynical that he wants to chop
her head up but obviously he can't do
that so instead he goes home and has
Patrick Bateman do it instead venting
through his art Bateman's outverse in
the story are often triggered by
something that upsets him like this he
enjoys reading about serial killers like
Ted Bundy Ed geen and Charlie Manson and
takes inspiration from each of them
before debatably surpassing them all it
was also at Harvard where Bateman
started dating a girl named Bethany he
would write long dark poems for her and
it's possible but not confirmed that she
was on the receiving end of some of his
rage he describes a lunch where she
dumped him with her arm in a sling and a
faint bruise above her cheek Bethany
leaves a lasting impression on him and
he treats her differently than all other
women there seems to be a deep yearning
for approval from her as opposed to the
other girls he dates who he disrespects
and couldn't care less about it's clear
that most of his targets are female but
were never explicitly told where
Patrick's mindset about women came from
but there is a line in the rules of
attraction where Sean notes that their
father is usually quite Adept at picking
up women despite most likely being
married if he's willing to cheat on his
wife quite often in front of their kids
it's not a stretch to assume that he's
not the best role model when it comes to
relationships but Patrick and Sean are
serial cheaters in their own dating
lives there's no evidence to suggest
that Mr Bateman also inspired Patrick to
take part in physically abusive Behavior
but there's also no evidence to suggest
that he didn't when talking about some
of the elements of American Psycho that
were drawn from his own life Brett East
and Ellis brings up his own father
American Psycho is in many ways an
autobiographical book I really have to
look back and look at my father in a lot
of ways his attitude towards women which
did border on the misogynistic influence
and informed this book and I think in a
lot of ways when I was writing about
Patrick Bateman it was really a lot of
it was about my dad if Patrick did
inherit some undesirable traits from his
father he may have also inherited
unwanted traits from his mom she seems
to have some kind of severe mental
illness as well though we never get any
good details on it other than being a
psycho or a psychopath as the title
suggests there are plenty of other
disorders that seem to fit his behavior
like antisocial personality disorder
narcissistic personality disorder
borderline personality disorder and
probably others I'm not going to go
through them all it's more efficient if
I just talk about the symptoms in
adulthood Patrick works at the
investment banking firm Pearson Pierce
in New York City and lives in a luxury
apartment on the upper west side of
Manhattan he probably got this job due
to his upper class education and his
father's influence in the industry
however he clearly didn't want to work
too closely with his dad otherwise he
might have just worked for him directly
Patrick is also very particular about
his appearance and has a detailed
grooming routine in addition to a
rigorous workout schedule at some point
he had a personal trainer but when the
trainer started to come on to him he
fired him and started developing his own
exercise program the word homophobic
gets used incorrectly a lot these days
in place of the word heterosexist but I
am making no mistake when I say Patrick
is homophobic the exercise program is
part of an obsession he has with his
appearance it's likely that this
obsession is part of his desire to fit
in which is also why he's obsessed with
popular culture he rents so many movies
that he becomes a gold Circle member at
the video store allowing him to
theoretically rent as many videos as he
wants on a given night provided he
doesn't have any already overdue the
need to fit in with his peers also
eventually results in him getting a
girlfriend a blonde named Evelyn
Richards who also comes from a wealthy
family Evelyn is an executive at a
financial services company American
Express and they most likely met through
their group of mutual friends in some
ways Evelyn is the perfect match for him
because they're both extremely shallow
and only in the relationship for
superficial reasons Evelyn for wealth
and a fancy wedding and Patrick for a
trophy girl that he can walk all over
with no repercussions in practice they
still manage to torture each other but
they stay together for social reasons
it's practical because they both run in
the same circles we don't know exactly
when they got together in 1986 or 1987
Patrick attends the Kentucky Derby with
a bimbo named Alison Poole that doesn't
necessarily mean he was cheating on
Evelyn at the time but it certainly
wouldn't be above him if he was cheating
on her with Allison it wouldn't be the
last time that he cheated on her at a
Kentucky Derby in January 1987 Patrick
and Strong's mother is committed to a
mental institution called sandstone and
Patrick's only reaction is it was about
time two months later around the time of
Sean's 21st birthday he discovers that
his father is dying Mr Bateman's face
turns yellow and it becomes extremely
thin during this time Patrick starts to
take over some responsibilities is the
family patriarch for example he puts
seven thousand dollars in Sean's bank
account so he's taken care of at College
do not mistake this for him caring about
his brother he is only doing this so he
can hold it above his head later which
he does Patrick turns 26 years old in
October of 87 and goes to the Bahamas
with Evelyn which is a really weird time
to get I would never go somewhere that
Sunny during spooky season and before
you say anything yes La is an exception
because they're like 30 haunts to
experience by early November Patrick's
father is on his deathbed so he makes
arrangements for Sean to come in and
visit one last time but when Sean is
late he thinks that he must be off doing
drugs and holds him into disdain for his
lack of responsibility as we will find
out Patrick has a problem with drugs of
his own and he often holds others to a
higher standard than himself as he waits
in the hospital Lobby he makes multiple
attempts to call Evelyn but she refuses
to come to the hospital at one point she
claims to be asleep but he hears faint
music in the background the earliest of
his suspicions that she isn't faithful
to him either it's pretty messed up to
cheat on someone who is about to be
mourning the loss of a parent but this
is another example of hypocrisy because
Bateman is seemingly never faithful to
her another hypocritical moment can be
seen when Sean arrives at the hospital
and Patrick grills him on his lack of
Direction in life telling him he should
try to become the son that his father
wanted despite this Patrick is planning
to go against his father's wishes after
his death by firing the AIDS that he
doesn't like he also seems to hint that
he'll be cutting off funding for Sean's
College degeneracy he would be pleased
to know that you're taking let's call it
a leave of absence from that place he
explains this causes Sean to storm out
claiming he'll go to Utah or Europe
before taking the limo back to his dad's
place throughout the hospital scene
Patrick is never shown to spend any time
with his father for him it's all about
making arrangements and The Business of
running the family there are a couple
outbreaks on his timeline over the next
few months that Christmas he went to
Aspen Colorado for some skiing and
violated a waitress with a can of
hairspray in the spring he videotapes
the torture and demise of two escort
girls and that takes us up to the
beginning of American Psycho the events
of the novel began on April 1st 1988
it's April Fool's Day which is a fitting
day to start a story where we have no
idea what's real and what's not half the
time they even is spending the day with
his co-worker Timothy price by having
lunch playing squash and getting drinks
at Harry's where price continually rants
about the Fisher account that Paul Owen
has handling something about this day
spent with price seems to leave a big
impression on Bateman and from this
point on he almost seems to model
himself after prize for one he becomes
obsessed with the Fisher account during
a cab ride price complains about not
making enough money at Pearson Pierce as
well as all the issues plaguing their
City primarily the Beggars for these
wealthy Wall Street investment bankers
the world revolves around social status
which is basically dictated by money the
homeless have no money so they're at the
bottom of the totem pole Bateman and
price look down on them as a result I
mean the Man's last name is price it's
almost two on the nose and speaking of
name etymology Patrick's girlfriend is
named Evelyn Richards and she's Rich
Patrick himself the star of American
Psycho has the last name abatement which
sounds very similar to Bates as in and
Norman Bates the main bad from Alfred
Hitchcock's Psycho there's even a little
reference in the book when one of
Bateman's colleagues goes to Phoenix
Phoenix Janet Lee was from Phoenix I
stall then continue she got stabbed in
the shower disappointing scene I pause
blood looked fake but his Bateman and
price are riding in the cab there's a
newspaper story about two people who
disappeared on a yacht party hosted by a
New York socialite where blood residue
and smash champagne glasses are found
Foul Play is suspected but it's not
clear if Bateman is responsible in truth
I'd like to talk about all of his
attacks in this video but many of them
are mentioned in passing as if they are
a minor detail leading me to feel like
he doesn't even mention most of them to
the reader upon getting out of the taxi
they tease a beggar by mockingly
offering the cab up to him and asking if
he takes American Express credit cards
Patrick and his associates constantly
bait the homeless like this every time
they see one at the very least it's a
cruel prank and at the worst it's a sign
of the mercilessness they have towards
those they see as lower than them in
Patrick's case this translates to a
brutal lack of empathy for victims of
all types price can be heard grumbling
about how he forgot to turn the tapes he
rented last night to videohaven and if
you've seen anything related to American
Psycho you know that returning
videotapes becomes a major aspect of
Patrick's personality either he's taking
after Prize or the two are being
portrayed as interchangeable once again
highlighting the dull banality of the
upper class they're headed to Evelyn's
house for dinner where we see what I
think is one of the most Psychopathic
traits Bateman has he encyclopedically
identifies what type of clothing every
single character wears and what brand
each piece of clothing is from each time
we see them for the entire novel this is
perhaps the earliest example of
Bateman's fervent obsession with
material things if I had to describe
Patrick Bateman in just a few words it
would be a man driven to psychopathy in
his pursuit of materialism at the end of
the day he's really just an exaggerated
product of his time here on this channel
we've already talked about many horror
properties in the 1980s that are driven
by the rabbit consumer culture Halloween
3 is about a Sinister salesman who uses
advertising and product frenzy to
brainwash and kill children stranger
things 3 which has not yet released a
videotape like the first two seasons
uses a shopping mall as a cover for a
secret terrorist base the original
Child's Play Even presents subtextual
themes of the harmful nature of product
and toy Mania during the holiday season
American Psycho takes a slightly
different approach by making the
consumer the villain rather than the
victim in short the main reason for the
Boost in product sales commercials and
the commodification of material Goods in
the 1980s was the booming economy and in
the United States reduced taxes and
government regulations encyclopedia.com
has a page on 1980s Commerce that offers
the perfect explanation for Patrick
Bateman's behavior for the average
American the booming economy of the
1980s meant a rise in disposable income
the money that people have to spend on
items that they do not need but wants
many Americans engage in conspicuous
consumption purchasing luxury goods to
show others that they're doing well in
American Psycho we see Patrick Bateman
and become so obsessed with conspicuous
consumption that it basically dictates
every decision he ever makes in a novel
we see that he is essentially
brainwashed to notice how decadent the
clothing others are wearing is above
anything else I do not exaggerate when I
say probably 25 percent of the book is
just Bateman describing clothing and
other luxury items this is his primary
barometer in judging people they arrive
at Evelyn's and they're greeted by her
friend Courtney who flirts with Patrick
the plan is to have a suit Sushi night
in which annoys the men because they
won't be able to show off their wealth
by dining out in a fancy restaurant
eating in will not increase their social
status and won't give Patrick the rush
of dopamine he gets from flashing his
Platinum American Express card at a busy
restaurant they're also joined by two of
Evelyn's artist friends who are
basically metal heads and Bateman looks
down on them thinking the male friend
would probably be unable to secure a
table at camels which I'm assuming is a
restaurant or Club in New York getting
reservations and getting into high
profile events provides Patrick with a
similar Rush of dopamine due to my
career as a content creator the feeling
associated with getting into VIP events
is one of the few aspects of the
character that I can relate to the
difference being that I don't have the
social battery to go out all the time
however I know that these people exist
because I do see them whenever I go to
Creator events there are certain people
who seem to be at everyone you know who
you are during the dinner at Evelyn's
Patrick goes on a Manifesto speech about
the problems currently facing their
society but we have to end apartheid for
one and slow down the nuclear arms race
stop terrorism and world hunger however
many of the concerns he lists are
completely hypocritical and his actions
actively say otherwise he is extremely
classes so he doesn't care about
apartheid he even later admits that he
has a pro-apartheid stance he claims we
need to care for the elderly yet his
mother suffers in some kind of Elderly
Care Facility or mental hospital and he
rarely visits her despite claiming we
need to stop crime and drugs on our
streets he commits crimes and buys
illegal drugs as a hobby he advocates
for training and jobs for the unemployed
and Sheltering the homeless then spends
the entire book torturing the homeless
for not having a job he Raves about
freedom of choice in terms of abortion
but later forces a woman he's seeing to
get an abortion he says we have to curb
graphic sex and violence on TV in movies
and in popular music and most ironically
we have to promote General Social
concern
unless materialism everything he's
saying just consists of talking points
that he's probably heard or read
somewhere which he doesn't believe in
whatsoever but he wants to use to gain
favor with his colleagues his
never-ending quest to increase his
social status extends Beyond just
flashing his money his entire social
life revolves around fitting in because
I want to fit in Courtney and the two
artist types leave so Evelyn price and
Bateman continue to chat over some
drinks where Bateman notices his vodka
cranberry looking like a glass of watery
blood the very earliest and most subdued
of his violent thoughts and Fantasies
which we'll get into more later in his
story price and Evelyn openly flirt in
front of him leading him to conclude
that they're having an affair he thinks
price is the most interesting man he
knows yet their conversations only
revolve around the discussion of
superficial things in the hierarchy of
Wall Street investment guys price is
considered more valuable than him
leading him to believe that Evelyn would
prefer prize eventually price leaves and
after 15 minutes of trying to coerce his
girlfriend to go to bed with him Bateman
gives up and goes home to take care of
himself five weeks after this on May 7
1988 he joined Evelyn and her parents in
a trip back to the Kentucky Derby where
he cheated on her again and won a lot of
money off a horse called indecent
exposure we next check in on him later
that month as he does his morning
stretches and goes through his
unbelievably detailed grooming machine
showing the true extent of his obsession
with his appearance and more importantly
the money that goes into upholding his
Perfect Image Bateman also has a bizarre
fixation with the daytime television
program The Patty winter show throughout
the story we see him interact with many
pop culture phenomena of the 1980s
because his entire personality revolves
around fitting in he doesn't form any of
his own opinions about pop culture he
just likes whatever is hit a term that
comes up many times throughout the novel
it turns out Bateman is not a based man
The Paddy winter show is the fictional
equivalent of daytime talk shows that
blew up in the 80s like Sally Geraldo
and most notably the Oprah Winfrey Show
which was probably the basis for Patty
Winters they both interviewed Donald
Trump in the late 80s and share a few
other common segments as well Patrick
makes a note of many Paddy Winter's
Topics in his interior monologue but
they cannot always be taken at face
value this morning's show is about women
with multiple personalities which seems
like a believable topic for a daytime
talk host Oprah herself covered it in
1990 but throughout the story The
segments on Paddy Winters get stranger
and stranger and many have suggested
that this is a reflection of Patrick's
own sound he's starting to sweat Patrick
even admits at one point that he might
have been hallucinating while watching
it as I mentioned Bateman's reliability
as a narrator comes into question at
some point as his mind delves into
strange and unbelievable fantasies so
the topic of each Paddy winter show may
help us differentiate fact from fantasy
at times which I'll get into later but
first we would find out just how Wild
the night out on the town can get when
money is No Object and the drinks are
flowing early at Harris
[Music]
Bateman goes with Timothy price to meet
with two other associates David Van
Patton and Craig McDermott for drinks at
Harry's they quiz him about style tips
and Bateman and price battle to impress
their friends with their knowledge of
high-end clothing etiquette price seems
to have the upper hand at this point I'd
consider price to be the leader of the
group when another colleague Preston
joins the conversation price makes a
joke about blowing his [__] friend's
heads off with a 38 Magnum while Patrick
would eventually not hesitate to say
outlandish stuff like this he is more
reserved early on it's possible that
seeing price get away with making a joke
about killing his friends is what gives
Bateman the confidence to openly speak
out the dark thoughts going on in his
brain later on these comments always get
brushed off as a joke or misheard he
definitely takes after price in many
other ways too in fact just about
everyone in their Community is trying to
be like someone richer and more powerful
than themselves which leads to an entire
industry of guys in their late 20s all
trying to look the same with no
personality of their own we see this
immediately after as price mistakes a
man standing at the bar for one of their
co-workers this is something that comes
up time and time again the idea of
mistaking a person's identity Patrick
makes a mental note and uses this to his
Advantage later on the constant
misidentification among colleagues
satirizes the Society of yuppies or
young urban professionals a term that
arose in the early 80s to describe the
growing culture of young adults with
high-paying jobs and fashionable
lifestyles in fact if you look at the
portrayal of yuppies in books magazines
or television at the time you might have
a hard time distinguishing them from
something out of American Psycho the
topic of conversation changes to Paul
Owen the manhandling the coveted Fisher
account Bateman calls out Preston for
making an anti-semitic remark about Owen
and later is the only one who refuses to
laugh at Preston's racist joke which the
others chalk up to Patrick trying to
take The High Ground because Evelyn is
part of the American civil liberties
Union oh I forgot Bateman's dating
someone from the ACLU after ditching
Preston they get into a cabin go to
dinner only then realizing nobody has
made a reservation anywhere and Patrick
describes his feeling of panic when this
happens while most would not consider
this a big deal Bateman doesn't want to
be seen in public with no dinner because
that doesn't align with his high-powered
image they make reservations at pastels
and when they show up a few minutes
later they're able to be seated
immediately because McDermott knows the
maitre d Bateman is envious of this
because that's the end goal for him
using his power money and connections to
get whatever he wants in life and
further boost his image the table even
gets a free round of bellinis from the
maitre d but price has them sent away to
re-establish his dominance over the guru
they're approached by yet another fellow
Banker named Scott Montgomery but
Montgomery's status by far outweighs
their own and the group ogles over how
much money he's worth and how attractive
his date is after he walks away in their
eyes these things go hand in hand
everything including women is a status
symbol Bateman tries to take back some
of the attention by showing off his new
business card in the book the business
card scene takes place with them still
in the restaurant pastels but in the
movie it happens in their office so I'm
just gonna show that use your
imagination each of the men tries to
one-up Bateman by showing off their own
business cards to which Bateman
describes himself as being overcome with
a spasm of jealousy I can't believe that
Bryce prefers van Patt hard to mine to a
normal person they all look the same
however they're all chasing Yuppie
Trends just like how their clothing and
haircuts make them look
indistinguishable from one another to
them in a world where everyone in their
circles is Rich everyone is good looking
and everyone has everything in terms of
material Goods these subtle differences
are a huge deal another status symbol to
quarrel over we see it affect Patrick
seemingly more than anyone else his
entire self-worth is Shattered by not
having the best card leaving him
unexpectedly depressed and causing him
to have a huge angry Outburst at
McDermott where he explains why the red
snapper Pizza isn't good at this
restaurant like his assertations about
what clothing can be paired together his
knowledge of what menu items are hip
comes from magazines or restaurant
guides there's no need to decide whether
he likes the pizza for himself because
it would not be a good look to go
against the mainstream opinion staying
hip is all that matters in fact when
their appetizers come they don't even
eat them before they're taken away which
I see is the men just wanting to be seen
receiving the appetizers Bateman also
grabs a waitress and tells her they're
planning to spend a lot of money while
slipping her a 50 Bill to ensure that
their table be allowed to smoke cigars
in the restaurant without any complaints
from fellow patrons being considered
this power move impresses the other man
all is well as they continue to talk
while ogling at hard body waitresses a
term that they use to describe
attractive women taken from the 1984
movie hard bodies once again
demonstrating the control that pop
culture has over them hard bodies you
know little foxes down on the beach they
receive a champagne bottle from Scott
Montgomery and price is insulted because
it's non-vintage which he sees as cheap
the forehead to a nightclub called
tunnel where they don't meet the dress
code but price manages to get them in
anyway Bateman assumes he does this by
offering a generous tip McDermott is
still complaining about not getting the
red snapper pizzas and Bateman has an
urge to knife him and slice his face
open but price sends McDermott and Van
Patten away with the two VIP basement
passes he received allowing him to take
Bateman to buy some cocaine and price
knows all the right people to talk to
keep in mind that while the characters
value drugs I am in no way promoting or
glorifying them I am simply discussing
what happened in a documentary context
so that I can better explain the role
that they play in the character's
downfall after doing coke in the
bathroom they're disappointed the
strength of the drug and the amount they
received demonstrating that this is a
very regular thing for them and alluding
to the addiction problems that Bateman
would eventually face not just with
drugs but with everything that gives him
pleasure from dining out to adult films
to hacking up and slashing hard bodies
he goes back to the bar to get them more
drinks and is told that the drink
tickets that they received had expired
and it would be a cash bar for the rest
of the night 25 dollars
[Music]
this is the first time that Patrick's
homicidal thoughts slip out but his
voice is drowned out by the music so he
faces no consequences however the more
he does this the more careless he
becomes so we'll come back to it price
who has been agitated the entire night
tells Bateman that he's leaving which
Bateman perhaps because of the drugs
doesn't understand no Bateman I'm
serious you dumb son of a [__] leaving
disappearing and disappear he does price
stands up on a railing with a champagne
glass and then says goodbye [__] heads
before running away into the train
tunnel after which the club is theme we
don't see price again for almost three
years after this which coincides with
Bateman spending the next three years in
a downward spiral the next morning
Patrick arrives at work and has an
encounter in the elevator where he's
confused for someone named Marcus when
he arrives he tells the secretary Gene
that he came late due to an aerobics
class which is most likely a lie that he
devises to hide the hangover he probably
had from the previous night he's aware
that Gene is in love with him and he
thinks he'll probably end up marrying
her he is correct but we'll talk more
about that after the events of American
Psycho Gene updates him on the day's
meetings which he tells her to cancel
just saying no he instead has her make
lunch and dinner reservations for him
causing her to ask if the dinner is
something romantic he tells her no and
just says he'll make them himself the
truth is that he's taking his mistress
Courtney out for a date that evening he
may be shy about this because he
actually likes Jean and when she follows
his orders he even mentions how he's
touched and flattered by her almost
total Devotion to him there's never a
point where he thinks of Evelyn in such
a positive light despite this he scolds
Jean for the way that she's dressed and
gives her Specific Instructions to wear
a dress or skirt with high heels simply
because he likes them and probably
because he feels the need to control her
in some way and knows that she'll comply
he spends his time at the office doing
everything but working rearranging the
decor listening to music reading Sports
Illustrated and watching TV the question
of how Patrick still has a job if he
never works is never explicitly detailed
but at one point the fact that his
family owns some kind of large company
is brought up which I took as his
father's company having a good
relationship with the company that works
at essentially meaning that his job is
safe although he has the means to quit
working altogether he continues to work
in order to fit in I don't think there's
one scene in the book where we actually
see a character getting worked on
apparently this wasn't originally
supposed to be the case when Ellis set
out to write the book
when I started working on American
Psycho I was actually very interested in
Wall Street and I really wasn't
interested in the business aspect of it
and so when I started doing research on
the book I hung out with guys who worked
in firms and on the stock exchange and
stuff I would ask some questions about
our jobs no one really wanted to talk
about her jobs they wanted to talk about
clothing in their house in the Hamptons
who could get a better table which
restaurant it was really about status
and that's when the book began to shift
for me and began to take shape as I
alluded to before Bateman is an
unreliable narrator it isn't always
clear how much time passes in between
his stories or what goes on in between
it seems to be a different day when he
talks about his health club visit his
trip to the video store to re-rent body
double because he's turned on by the
scene of the woman getting killed by the
power drill and his next date with
Courtney then I believe it's a different
day when he gets a shiatsu massage and
stops at a newsstand where the vendor
alerts him that his nose is bleeding
Patrick doesn't make a big deal out of
it but I would speculate that the
nosebleed is a symptom of his increased
cocaine usage the first time we see him
do it it seems like he's just trying to
fit in with price but we would soon see
him seeking it out on his own the idea
is further later that day when Bateman
meets actor Tom Cruise in the elevator
at his building and Tom alerts him to
another nosebleed which he casually
tries to rectify with a handkerchief
during the elevator ride Bateman sucks
up to Tom telling him how much he's a
fan of his work Tom acts like he doesn't
really want to talk to Bateman treating
him with two or three word answers not
too different from the way that Bateman
treats the co-workers that he doesn't
really respect he returns home to find
messages on his answering machine from
that evening's dinner date Patricia who
wants to change the plans and take
Patrick to a concert instead he is
vehemently against this and claims that
he doesn't like live music this has
always struck me as strange because he
does like recorded music the Huey Lewis
scene is easily the most famous scene in
the movie and there are no less than
three chapters in the book completely
dedicated to just Patrick reviewing
music after pondering this for a while I
don't think there's an obvious reason
that he feels differently about live
music perhaps he doesn't like the
improvisational nature of it and not
knowing what to expect gives him a sense
of not having control perhaps being a
Wall Street Banker he doesn't have
connections in the music industry as he
does in others and if he can't get
special VIP treatment he doesn't want to
be seen in the crowd with the commoners
whatever the case may be he uses
manipulation tactics to get her to
change her mind such as suggesting that
he'll find someone else to go to dorsia
with him dorsia is the hottest
restaurant in the city and even Bateman
has so far been unable to get a
reservation there upon hearing this
magic word Patricia changes her tune and
agrees to dinner with him so he tells
her to be over at 8pm after getting off
the phone he hurriedly calls dorsia to
see if he can get a table but is unable
to get anything but a busy signal for
several minutes this process gives him
an adrenaline rush which he refers to as
the rarest of occurrences we've only
seen him experience this kind of emotion
a couple times comparing business cards
and now trying to get a table at Dorsey
when it comes to committing crimes or
talking to women he's cool as a
Manhattan's winter night he even sends
his bloody articles to a dry cleaner
with No Reservations about getting
caught but put him in a situation where
his social status is on the line and
watch The Sweat Beads begin to fold when
he finally gets through and requests a
table for two the voice on the other
line laughs at him Bateman has finally
found a privilege that money can't buy
and while most others might be turned
off by the rude treatment from the
restaurant worker this only fuels his
desire to get into dorsia in the future
before the night he gets reservations at
Barcadia which at other times is
referred to as Arcadia actually it's not
really clear if these are two separate
restaurants or if this is another
example of a mental slip Bateman
accidentally misidentifying the name of
it half the time while waiting for his
date to arrive he makes a decision about
her fans I come to the conclusion that
Patricia is safe tonight and I'm not
going to unexpectedly pull out a knife
and use it on her just for the sake of
doing so that I am not going to get any
pleasure watching her bleed from slits
that I've made by cutting her throats or
slicing her neck open or gouging her
eyes out she's lucky even though there's
no real reasoning behind the luck it
could be that she's safe because of her
wealth her family's wealth protects her
tonight or it could be that it's simply
my choice he waits until they're in the
cab to break the news to Patricia making
up a story to explain how the
reservation at dorsia got messed up upon
hearing this she turns away and pouts
for the entire evening the situation
doesn't seem to be lost on Bateman she
was only using him to go to the hottest
destination possible and for sex and he
was only using her as a good looking
accessory and for sex however he decides
he no longer wants to sleep with her
because he's rubbed the wrong way by her
behavior and decides to get revenge on
her by taking her to the nightclub
tunnel after dinner and ignoring her
there he goes straight to the bar and
gets his favorite drink J and B on the
Rocks Jane B is a brand of Scotch and
back then they advertised it as being a
high class beverage so it makes sense
that Bateman would want to associate
himself with it I guess today people see
it as more of a chief brand but at the
bar he realizes that the entire Club is
empty we are except for the occasional
Hardbody literally the only two people
in Tunnel New Sensation becomes the
devil inside and the music is full blast
but it feels less loud because there
isn't a crowd reacting to it and the
dance floor looks vast when empty these
are the same two songs that played the
first time we saw Bateman at this club
right before he and price went to
purchase the coke this makes me wonder
if the empty Club is merely one of
Bateman's hallucinations in particular
the song The Devil Inside by INXS brings
to mind a later hallucination of his
involving the devil which we'll get to
the name of the band INXS also feels
significant because the pronunciation is
a phonetic play on the words in excess
and pertaining to the point I've been
driving home throughout this video
Bateman is a man pushed to psychopathy
by living an excessive lifestyle he
attempts to mimic what Timothy price
would do by wandering off and finding
Ricardo the man that sold them the
cocaine in the basement Ricardo is with
a woman who compliments him on his
wallet and he tells her that he'd like
to do unmentionable things to her and
maybe cut her arms off but again the
loud music seems to muffle his voice but
we can see that he's becoming more
comfortable with the off-color remarks
again this takes after Price's Behavior
but Bateman takes it too far and I'm
guessing he takes the cocaine usage too
far as well because this is where things
really get weird after getting them
drinks Patricia comes back and goes on a
long-winded apology for her behavior
earlier in the night but Bateman
basically Tunes her out and starts
thinking about expensive material things
he wants in an almost robotic methodical
fashion Patricia is never mentioned
again so it's unclear if he simply
dumped her or changed his mind about her
being safe for the evening the next
scene features Bateman taking bloody
articles to the dry cleaners so I'll let
you be the judge his usual dry cleaners
had sent his stuff back last time still
bloodstained so this time he goes in
person to complain he's unable to
communicate with the chinese-speaking
woman who works there in his frustration
he threatens to kill her and it's
unclear if she understands him he
Daydreams about firebombing the whole
place I am not condoning such in action
this is just an educational character
analysis documentary when another
customer walks in he quickly tries to
recompose himself demonstrating that
he's still attempting to keep up the
appearance of a sane member of society
it turns out to be a woman from his
building Victoria he mistakes her for a
Samantha at first The misidentification
Motif goes both ways it seems he asks
her if she can try to talk to the
screeching Chinese woman behind the
counter explaining that he got Crown
apple juice on his sheets and needs the
stains removed he doesn't seem concerned
about his weak excuse for why his sheets
are stained red I think he's so cocky
about his high place up in society that
he genuinely doesn't believe that he
could ever be suspected or caught and
Society kind of proves him right there
are other similar moments in the movie
like the one where he's loading a body
into the trunk of a cab and the only
reaction he gets is
where did you get that overnight back as
he's leaving Samantha tries to set up a
date with him the following week but he
makes several excuses as to why he's
busy because she's a little overweight
that afternoon Bateman's increasing
frequency of hallucinations are
confirmed when he mistakes a college
student for a homeless girl and puts it
dollar into a coffee cup then in the cab
he says he hallucinated the whole city
into mountains volcanoes and jungles he
describes his lunch appointment as a
permanent hallucination involving waking
dreams although he never tries to
diagnose what's going on with himself
this is almost certainly an example of
cocaine-induced psychosis this is the
process of cocaine use altering
chemicals in the brain causing the
subject to lose touch with reality with
symptoms such as seeing hearing or
feeling things that are not there and
inappropriate behavior the increasingly
severe psychosis may be reflected in the
next Patty winter show topic real life
rambos which Bateman sees in the morning
before having drinks at Harry's with
Todd Hamlin and George Reeves Paul Owen
stops by their table and confuses
Bateman for another associate Marcus
halberstadt whose job fashion sense and
hairdo are all very similar to Patrick's
making it an understandable mistake he
gets Owen's card and the two plan to
have drinks sometime as Owen leaves one
of his friends looks back and seems to
recognize Bateman with a panicked look
which in turn makes Bateman uneasy one
evening Courtney invites Bateman out to
dinner with another couple and because
her boyfriend Lewis Carroll others is
out of town on business before going out
he has jeans study the menu and prepare
three different possible orders for him
in the cab he thinks he sees Donald
Trump's car not only is this another
example of mistaken identity but it's
also one of the many examples of Bateman
idolizing Donald Trump keep in mind this
was the 1980s and at the time Trump was
a young real estate developer who
basically achieved Celebrity Status due
to his life of wealth and access he was
basically the ultimate Yuppie the very
thing that Bateman aspired to be
apparently in his later years Trump
shifted gears to become some kind of
politics Guy this is still a politics
free Channel I just felt it necessary to
remind you that Bateman's Idol at the
time was known for different reasons
because this reverence does come up
again later the restaurant that they go
to is called a deck chairs which serves
post-california Cuisine and the couple
that they dine with are named Scott and
Anne Smiley also for the first time in a
while we're given a clue about the dates
because Scott mentions that he just
picked up the new Phil Collins album and
the song Groovy Kind of Love sounds
really good Groovy Kind of Love is on
Phil Collins Buster soundtrack which
came out September 19 1988 and Bateman
does mention that it's a Monday so the
date is Monday September 19 1988. Scott
and Anne are both graduates of Camden
University Camden is the setting of
Brett Easton Ellis's previous novel The
Rules of Attraction and if you've read
that novel this scene probably felt very
familiar it contained a scene where
Patrick's brother Sean and his
girlfriend Lauren go out for
post-california Cuisine with the very
same couple and Scots the entire
interaction is exactly the same it
starts with Anne deciding not to drink
alcohol then abatement Brother Talks
with Scott about his new CD player then
Scott talks about how he just bought a
new Phil Collins CD these similarities
are far too specific to be considered a
coincidence and given Patrick's
psychosis I have to believe that this
whole evening is modern hallucination it
seems that Sean told him his story at
some point about his awkward double date
with the Smileys and Patrick during a
wild and powdery evening with Courtney
somehow convinced his overly medicated
brain that this was his own experience
his tendency to mix stories he has heard
into his own narrative is an important
clue for helping us decipher future
events we've already seen him start to
struggle with distinguishing reality
like during during this dinner when he
tells Anne did anyone ever tell you that
you look exactly like Garfield but run
over and skinned and then someone threw
an ugly Ferragamo sweater over you
before they rushed you to the vet which
is definitely going to become my new
rejection line just kidding but this
line does show that Patrick has
definitely stopped differentiating
between things that actually happened
and things that he only fantasized about
we can see that much by the fact that
Anne doesn't react to his rude comment
meanwhile Courtney is nearly falling
asleep at the table due to some drugs
that she's taken and Bateman is not
enjoying the evening at all he thinks to
himself that no female intimacy is worth
sitting through this dinner and his mind
begins to wander to chopping up Ann and
Scott He videotapes they forgot to
return and the adult video that he
watched recently which he can't get his
mind off of like the drugs he's been
taking the adult content is starting to
become an addiction which we can see by
the fact that he starts thinking about
it at inappropriate times at some point
Courtney disappears to use the bathroom
and Patrick finds her asleep in the
coach check room 30 minutes later this
is where the best move is to make sure
she gets home safely and let her beg for
your forgiveness the next day but that's
not what happens because statement is
becoming more depraved and more deviant
by the diet during their encounter later
that night he hears her say Lewis is a
Despicable twit but this was partially
just his imagination she actually says
is it a receptacle tip I think she meant
is it a reservoir tip but as we know
Courtney isn't the smartest they get
into a huge argument about the method of
contraception something Courtney is
concerned about only because it affects
how she looks in a bikini and she starts
crying Patrick and Courtney's ability to
be intimate with each other would soon
be cut short Lewis Carruthers was coming
home from Phoenix
[Music]
shortly after Lewis returns from his
business trip in Phoenix and Bateman
shows up to work hungover after another
debaucherous evening The Paddy Winters
topic that morning was descendants of
the downer party and if Bateman really
is hallucinating Paddy Winter's topics
it's a grim foreshadowing of things to
come because the Donner party was a
group of settlers who got snowbound in
the mountains and had to resort to
cannibalism mean they ate each other off
they had to in order to survive during
the meeting McDermott still salty about
baymen insulting his red snapper pizza
at pastels it brings in a Xerox article
about Donald Trump where Trump claims
that pastels has the best pizza in
Manhattan seeing this actually causes
Bateman to admit how he'll have to try
the pizza again now I think this
exchange demonstrates more than any
other that Bateman truly has no
personality of his own everything is
dictated by what's hip and something as
subjective as personal taste is treated
as fact so long as the rich and trendy
agree Bateman continues to go through
his routine and the violent thoughts
become a more and more frequent he
thinks about taking a hammer and ice
pick to a girl at the video store and
tells him a series that he'd like to
transfuse a hardbody's blood with dog
blood the Patty winter segments get more
bizarre with segments like UFOs that
kill he also spent some time with Marcus
halberstam's girlfriend perhaps he's
trying to learn more about Marcus in
order to better emulate him his next
supposed victims are two black kids he
saw on the subway station and he also
takes credit for killing Evelyn's
neighbor whose head he saw it off with
an electric mini chainsaw before storing
get in his freezer this one is more
likely to be real because Evelyn calls
one night and admits she's shaken up by
it and her building is surrounded by
police one afternoon Patrick does some
early Christmas shopping for himself and
everything he buys is some form of Blade
a pair of scissors a letter opener and a
cheese knife while there's probably no
limit to how early a psychopath does
their early Christmas shopping for
themselves I'm gonna call this late
November that evening he has a date
planned with Courtney when his actual
girlfriend Evelyn calls still shaken by
her neighbor's death and demands to have
dinner with him during their meal at
Barcadia he fantasizes about seeing
Evelyn with another woman he doesn't
bother to cancel with Courtney the
rumors about their Affair have put a
strain on Courtney and Evelyn's
relationship but Bateman doesn't care
the conversation meanders from rumors
about where Tim price has been to Evelyn
mistaking another diner for Ivana Trump
which only infuriates Patrick Evelyn
starts gushing about weddings claiming
she won't settle for less than a diamond
engagement ring and Patrick says he'd
want to blow her fat mother's head off
at the ceremony obviously he didn't
really say that out loud because again
there's no reaction as the conversation
continues it seems that they are not
connecting at all either Patrick is
lying about all of his lines or Evelyn
isn't listening to a word he says in
reality I imagine it's a little bit of
both on a Tuesday Patrick is attending a
black tie party an exclusive and
luxurious event like this seems like
something that early Bateman would be
very interested in but he appears to
have grown bored with this kind of thing
and spends the whole party looking for
drugs even running into Courtney doesn't
seem to spark his interest as much and
he blows her off by telling her he has
to go return some videotapes as she
tries to warn him to stay away from
Lewis who apparently suspects something
between the two he ends up walking the
streets where he starts a conversation
with a bum named Al Bateman gets his
attention by offering money and food but
then just ends up scolding him why don't
you get a job if you're so hungry why
don't you get a job I lost my job why
you're drinking is that why you lost it
insider trading
just joking his immediate assumption
that the man lost his job for alcohol
abuse is either extremely ironic or some
form of self-conscious projection
because Bateman has completely lost
control of his life due to substance
abuse and his other addictions after
offering to help the guy out he suddenly
becomes very angry because of the man's
stench calls him a loser and stabs him
in the eye causing it to burst open he
continues to go at the guy with a knife
blinding him but being careful to keep
him alive however at this point I have
to question the validity of anything
that Patrick says he does and there's
very good reason to believe that some or
most of this horrible encounter with Al
never even happened but again we'll get
to that he decides to go to McDonald's
to get a milkshake normally he wouldn't
be caught dead at McDonald's but he sees
it as somewhere that Al would probably
go he is still supposedly covered in red
splatters of crime scene evidence but
that doesn't cause him to back down he's
just that cocky about not getting caught
the high from what he did to Al begins
to wear off and he finds himself still
wanting more what we're seeing is the
behavior of an addict with any addiction
it begins when the user engages in a
behavior that sends dopamine into the
reward circuit in the brain as the
behavior continues the brain adapts to
it which reduces the high that the
person feels from it this effect is
known as tolerance at this stage the
person may try to increase usage to get
the same high that they once felt and
these adaptations in the brain usually
cause the person to gain less pleasure
from other things the National Institute
of Health uses examples like food adult
activities and social interactions and
these examples actually perfectly apply
to Bateman he used to enjoy dining out
and extravagant 300 meals but now he's
bored by them and finds himself at
McDonald's we see him turn down a social
function in order to satisfy his
bloodlust normally one addiction is
enough to wreak havoc on a person's life
but for Bateman there are several
addictions substances sadism spending
and adult activity it's just to name a
few and by the way the only reason
Bateman is getting a dopamine Rush from
hurting people is because there is
something seriously wrong with his brain
so don't try it it will not make you
feel good if you want to feel a nice
charge try going to the gym or
subscribing to cz's world and leaving a
like on this video now I mentioned how a
person may increase their usage to try
to overcome desensitization and in
Bateman's case he's able to do this by
combining his addictions for a longer
dopamine hit but he's still able to
maintain the appearance of having some
level of control over his life perhaps
because everyone in his circles is so
shallow that they're only concerned with
material things and unable to recognize
his symptoms I don't think there's one
scene in the entire novel where he and
his friends or he and his girlfriend
have an actual conversation about each
other such as how they're feeling or how
they're doing case in point on another
day Bateman is having lunch with
Christopher Armstrong he works with him
at Pearson Pierce and Armstrong doesn't
even know who he is mistaking him for
someone named Taylor this must be the
most egregious mistaken identity yet the
two went to school together and they're
now out at launch Armstrong has just
returned from a vacation in the Bahamas
and when Bateman asks how it was he just
goes into this almost prepared sounding
pitch Armstrong has nothing to say about
anything he or his family did in the
Bahamas it's more like he's reciting a
paragraph directly out of a travel guide
it's almost exactly the same detached
passive voice that Bateman is when
talking about the things that he
supposedly likes there are three
chapters in American Psycho where
Bateman simply reviews the discography
of one of his favorite recording artists
the subjects are Genesis Whitney Houston
and of course Huey Lewis and the News
when Sports came out in 83 I think that
really came into their own commercially
and artistically yeah I mean I I
actually think he's correct there
Bateman's so-called opinion sound almost
as if they're ripped directly out of a
music Magazine's critique and they're
clearly written in language that is not
congress with how he speaks in
conversation or even in his interior
monologue I guess if you want to work at
Pearson Pierce you have to be completely
devoid of personality the Patty winter
show that day covers toddler tragedies
where the parents of children who are
kidnapped and off too soon or analyzed
by a panel of psychiatrists that one's
got to be a hallucination it's way too
dark to ever be considered for this type
of show it seems to be an indication
that Bateman is not mentally stable
which we see shortly after when he
mistakes a gay pride parade for a
Halloween parade on the way to Wall
Street this morning due to gridlock I
had to get out of the company car and
was walking down Fifth Avenue to find a
Subway Station when I passed what I
thought was a Halloween parade which was
disorienting since I was fairly sure
this was Meg since I've been keeping
track of the dates I can tell you it
most certainly is not me as we've
established it's definitely past
September at this point and possibly
into December since when is anybody only
fairly sure of what month it is I might
be fairly sure of the day of weeks
sometimes but I've never been unsure
where we are in the year that's
ridiculous I think this is another
example of Bateman's psychosis the
losing track of time that I alluded to
earlier he's losing his grip on reality
and this makes him an increasingly
unreliable narrator sure you could just
as well argue that any of the previous
mentions of the date are just as likely
to be mental slips but I believe that
this is the mental slip because as time
goes on he's getting more and more
detached from reality plus there is a
Christmas party a few chapters later
anyway the cat calls from the men
discussed him so much that he goes home
changes suits gives himself a pedicure
and tortures a dog to death all of these
are coping strategies but like I said
it's getting harder and harder for him
to cope because he's becoming more and
more used to the things that give his
brain to open me when putting on the
expensive clothes he's purchased no
longer has the same effect it once did
he's got to move on to more extreme
Solutions we see further evidence of him
getting bored with his extravagant life
on another evening when he cancels his
dinner reservations with Evelyn because
the thought of sitting alone with her
for that long fills him with nameless
dread he seems to be in almost a
depressive state but that changes when
he's invited to a U2 concert by Louis
carrada it's under normal circumstances
since he's not a fan of Lewis and not a
fan of live music he would probably just
say no however I think he agrees to go
because Lewis is also bringing Paul Owen
who of course is handling the Fisher
account and that's something that
interests him there are probably only a
few things that keep Bateman going at
this point in the story the things that
money is not able to buy him the
prestigious Fisher account and the
equally distinguished reservation at
dorsia during the outing Owen continues
to mistake Bateman for Marcus halberstam
and he even thinks that Evelyn is
Marcus's girlfriend Cecilia Evelyn
doesn't notice because she's too busy
glaring at Courtney who she is
suspicious of having an affair with
Patrick Patrick seems to be keeping up
this identity ruse for a reason and sure
enough he would use the mix-up to his
Advantage later despite having front row
seats nobody is interested in the
concert that is until Bateman sees the
backdrop turn red giving him a huge
surge of
he thinks he's receiving a message
directly from the front man bonna the
music slows down and the rest of the
audience and band members Fade Away Bano
tells him I am the devil and I am just
like you as you may recall this is
probably not the first time one of these
bizarre hallucinations makes reference
to the devil at this point I think we
can confidently say that Bateman is
psycho American psych there's also
another interesting parallel to the
rules of attraction here because at one
point Sean Bateman also sees the devil
while he's tripping after this Patrick
comes back down to reality and decides
it's finally time to ask Paul about that
fisher account if you think about it
it's funny that he wants the Fisher
account so badly yet he never actually
works it's just another status symbol
like everything in his life Owen
explains that he didn't even do anything
special to get it it just kind of fell
into his lap the next time we see Batman
he is in the throes of a major anxiety
attack one Thursday afternoon
[Music]
foreign
finds himself running around New York he
can't remember where he had lunch or
with whom he calls Gene his secretary
desperate for help and when he tells her
he won't make it to the office she shows
genuine sadness and concern she may be
the only one who ever shows these kinds
of genuine emotions he does so much
insane [__] on this afternoon that I
can't even fully list everything so I'll
just mention a few he shoplifts a can of
ham and eats it directly out of the
container in the lobby of the building
he obsessively States I've got to return
my videotapes over and over and he buys
five vials of drugs and eats them whole
before ranting to the dealer about BMW
engines then just as quickly as this
Insanity began it ends and Bateman finds
himself at the Yale club with McDermott
and Van Patten they talk fashion the gym
massages the usual he also sees Louis
Carruthers there and has an idea to kill
him wondering if he'd be able to spend
more time with Courtney if he did so or
if Courtney only likes him for the
thrill of going behind Lewis's back he
decides to go through with it and
follows him into the bathroom but when
he puts his gloved hands around Lewis's
neck to choke him Lewis kisses his wrist
and touches his face Bateman is so
shocked that he can't bring himself to
choke him and Lewis a closeted
homosexual has been pining for Bateman
for so long that he's unable to
interpret this as anything other than
Bateman coming onto him God
Patrick
why here I've seen you looking at me
I've noticed
your
hot wine unsure of how to respond
Bateman washes his hands glove's still
on and he's seeing it Lewis asked him
where he's going and he tells him he's
gotta return some videotapes whenever he
experiences this kind of discomfort he's
got to blow off the Steam and improve
his mood by releasing some dopamine he
works out three times in one day makes
some obscene and threatening telephone
calls to fuel his arousal and walks
around town with a briefcase full of
knives and guns he decides not to kill
the first two Targets he comes across on
the basis that they're too easy his
addiction is forcing him to search for a
bigger and bigger Rush finally he comes
across a gay man walking an expensive
sharp head the man flirts with Patrick
who exchanges pleasantries until he
randomly slices the dog's stomach open
and disembowels him he also stabs the
owner and shoots him with a silencer to
make sure he's really dead I'm a little
skeptical that this really happened
given that this takes place openly in
the streets of Manhattan and this is
still not enough to satiate him however
so he goes to the store and buys some
cereal with an expired coupon which
apparently gives him a thrill his crimes
are becoming more and more bizarre he
ends this Rampage by Run up and down
Broadway with an open umbrella screaming
like a banshee I wish they would have
put that in the movie on some other
evening his craving for all things
degenerate reaches an all-time high
after a dinner with Courtney that he
refers to as infuriating he drops her
off at Nell's nightclub and tells her
he'll return once he goes and gets some
drugs this does not end up being the
case he has his limo driver take him to
the meat packing District so he can look
for a blonde girl who seems suitable and
bribes her to come back to his place by
the way he seems to have no problem with
his limo driver bearing witness to his
illegal activities and this is never a
dress perhaps he's been giving a
generous tip to keep his mouth shut or
maybe none of this even happened this is
one of many examples of Bateman's
disregard of low-paid service industry
workers back at his apartment he orders
the girl to respond to the name Christy
then calls an escort service and soon
after another woman Sabrina arrives to
join them he sits her down and gives her
an expensive wine as they listen to the
Broadway cast recording of Les
Miserables on the stereo Les Miserable
comes up many times throughout American
Psycho 20 times to be exact it was a
popular Broadway show at the time and
it's two and deals with a character who
learns of the special privileges
afforded to the rich by Society
eventually things move to the bedroom
round one is innocuous enough but after
a short rest Bateman comes back for
round two which involves accessories
such as a nail gun sharpened coat hanger
butter knife matches and a cigar the
next day Sabrina leaves with a limp and
Christy with scratches and a black eye
as Christmas draws closer Bateman spends
most of his time going into cocktail
parties and Christmas shopping a
pleasurable activity for him because
it's another opportunity to gain favor
with others by showing off his fortune
he opts to do the shopping himself
rather than letting Gene do it because
of the rush he gets by making the
purchases instead he has jeans send out
holiday cards and do some research on
the Fisher account for him he also
mentions that he's been taking the
sleeping pill Halcyon in increasing
amounts during the day because even
though his body has adapted to it and it
no longer makes him sleep it does seem
to ward off total Madness just not quite
enough to prevent the idea of taking an
escort to Evelyn's Christmas party from
Crossing his head thankfully for her he
does not end up doing that the day of
the party he gets drinks at Rusty's in
order to fortify himself as if it's
going to be that unbearable after this
he jumps a Japanese delivery boy on a
bike and gives him a surprise Christmas
gift that is a slit to the throat and
this is kind of where I lose sympathy
for him taking out motorists is one
thing but targeting an innocent boy on a
bike that's just despicable he opens up
the food boxes that were being delivered
and he finds Chinese food not Japanese
and feels not remorse but irritation
because he got the wrong type of Asian
in his mind so are you Chinese or
Japanese he looks at the receipt and
makes a note to get revenge on the
person who had ordered the food as if
this was somehow her fault then shrugs
and apologizes to the delivery boy
before walking away I don't think it's
gonna do much good now though at the
Christmas party that evening he starts
to get nervous because he sees too much
red and is also off put by the short
people dressed as elves serving
appetizers and questions whether or not
he is hallucinating them this is telling
there are probably a lot of
hallucinations that he doesn't mention
to the reader considering he's at a
point where he's now questioning if real
things or hallucinations or not he only
realizes that they're real when Evelyn
mentions that she has names for all the
elves such as Rudolph Blitzen and Donner
Patrick corrects it I those are the
names of reindeer not elves Blitzen was
a reindeer he tells her the only Jewish
one Peterson reminds them I think
Peterson is talking about glimpses which
are a traditional Jewish recipe similar
to Crepes if not important to my
analysis I just thought it was an
underrated joke he tells Evelyn to be
grateful that he came to her Christmas
party when there are so many others that
he could have attended imagine skipping
out on your own girlfriend's Christmas
party the affair with Courtney is one
thing but that's just asking for trouble
speaking of whom Bateman sees Courtney
talking to Paul Owen across the room he
has the impression that she's flirting
with Paul which honestly wouldn't be
surprising given her shallowness and
attraction to Social Status however she
moves on and Bateman uses the
opportunity to get closer to the man who
is handling the coveted Fisher account
in talking to Owen he learns that
there's a limo waiting for him outside
to take Paul and his girlfriend to
Meredith to Nells after the party Paul
still thinks that Bateman is Marcus
halberstam and when Evelyn approaches
them he's under the impression that
she's halberstam's girlfriend Cecilia so
just to review Owen is at Evelyn's
Christmas party yet he still believes
that Evelyn is actually Cecilia I don't
even think I'm going to attempt to
explain how this is possible when Evelyn
starts to call him Patrick he creates a
big spectacle of calling her Cecilia
then kisses her and pulls her into the
kitchen he's clearly invested in keeping
up the ruse he doesn't want Paul to find
out that he's not really Marcus
halverstan it seems that he's already
planning on using Paul's confusion to
his advantage in the future though it's
not clear if he's already decided
exactly what he's going to do to further
sell the illusion he asks Evelyn to
leave the party with him he's worried
about her possibly tipping Paul off or
the real Marcus halberstam showing up
and shattering The Mirage Evelyn doesn't
want to leave her own party but he wins
her over by saying that leaving would be
daring which she likes the idea of and
he's able to play to her desires by
calling her Mrs Bateman and finally she
agreed outside he shoves her into Paul
Owens limo and tries to convince the
driver that Paul said he could take it
for the evening the driver doesn't
believe him and tells him that this
would break company protocol Patrick
considers trying to take another limo
but because he specifically wants Paul
Owens he bribes the man with 200 which
is enough to get him to comply and drive
them to Club Chernobyl once again we see
the lack of Chemistry Between Patrick
and Evelyn she's acting almost just as
crazy and entitled as her boyfriend she
finds a present in the limo and necklace
which Paul had left for Meredith and
assumes that it's hers she takes a
fortune cookie out of Patrick's pocket
and assumes it's some kind of clue that
Patrick will be taking her to lunch at
that restaurant in the future she thinks
she's in a game and everything is some
kind of hints despite the obvious fact
that Patrick doesn't really care for her
at all and only keeps her around as a
hot trophy girl when she realizes that
they're headed to Club Chernobyl she
pouts and tries to get the driver to
change course to the Rainbow Room which
Patrick does not want to do because he
knows he won't be able to score drugs
there this is textbook addict Behavior
he's always thinking ahead to where he
can get his next fix when they arrive at
Chernobyl the doorman lets them in
immediately because he saw that they got
out of a limo there's probably no better
moment to illustrate how wealth and
special privileges are tied to each
other in late 80s New York once inside
he sends Evelyn to go get some champagne
at bar so he can go look for a dealer
after obtaining some powder he comes
across a hard body and considers
ditching Evelyn for her showing that all
of the efforts and begging required to
get her out here was never about
spending time with her he just wanted
her to stay away from the party and
moreover he probably liked being able to
control her however she comes back
whining that they should leave because
they have the wrong brand of champagne
in many ways I think Evelyn would be
just as crazy as Patrick in terms of
psychotic consumerism if not for the
whole Patrick being a serial killer
thing looking for a private spot he
drags her to the unisex bathroom where
he gets into it with another couple over
whose turn it is to take the next
available stall the other couple is in
there for the same reason that Patrick
is Patrick insults the girl and calls
her a [__] to which her boyfriend just
laughs and refuses to defend her this
starts a fight between the woman and her
boyfriend and that causes Evelyn to get
mad at Patrick for starting it and she
tells him that she'll just wait outside
Patrick doesn't really care about Evelyn
being there anymore and he orders her to
just take the limousine and leave as he
gets down to it he can hear her sobbing
to the other girl about how he made her
walk out of her own Christmas party when
he finishes and walks back out the club
Evelyn is gone and the crowd has changed
it's less Wall Street guys and more punk
rockers and rappers when he tries
hitting on some girls his social class
actually works against him one of them
sneers and says go back to Wall Street
and the one with the nose ring says
[__] Yuppie he also makes an
embarrassing attempt to talk to some
black guys by using the words freshest
and deafest to no avail yo for the first
time his normally coveted lifestyle is
working against him and this is meant to
show how much further he can fall when
his dominant position over others is no
longer a reliable source of joy for him
American Psycho takes place near the end
of the Yuppie Tran it's currently late
1988 and the Yuppie lifestyle was
already starting to decline after a
stock market crash in 1987 reminded
people how volatile the economy could be
the end was already near and after a
short economic recession began in 1990
Time Magazine would post a mock obituary
called the birth and maybe death of
Yuppie Dum in April 1991. lucky for
Patrick Bateman he's able to find
another Hardbody dancing alone who is
more receptive to him that is the last
we see abatement in 1988 and the next
part of his timeline caused a lot of
confusion for me at the beginning of the
next chapter he claims it's now mid-may
however three chapters later it's
Shawn's 23rd birthday which would put us
in March 1989. I considered the
possibility that the story is being told
out of order but there is clearly a
linear sequence of events plus the
structure of the novel almost feels like
a journal that he's creating in his head
he's journaling it all as he goes along
I think the more likely explanation is
that Bateman's mind is really starting
to get distorted by the drugs we already
established one instance of this when he
mistook the Gay Pride Parade as a
Halloween parade according to the
British psychological Society the
consumption of drugs and alcohol has
long been known to warp time experiences
and many drug users support similar
experiences following marijuana cocaine
and alcohol use so I'm just going to
call this early 1989 and this is
supported by what happens in this
chapter he continues further down the
same path he was on being warped by his
addictions and corrupting more of his
thoughts he wakes up from a dream that
he describes as being lit like an adult
film where he was with girls made of car
cardboard perhaps a symbol of how he
sees their lives is disposable he also
meets with his lawyer about some bogus
rape charges and although Bateman is
never shy about the crimes he's
committed in the narration it's not hard
to imagine that these charges aren't so
bogus and he's simply done so much bad
stuff that he can't keep track of it all
he also describes an anxiety attack
suffered in a grocery store which he
worked off at the gym his gym time seems
to be increasing and ironically this is
the one healthy coping mechanism that he
seems to have but there's only so much
time he can spend at the gym and it's
not enough to outweigh all of the mental
issues that are piling up so he ends up
beating a girl begging for bus money
because she had misspelled the word
disabled on her sign he's living a
double life switching back and forth
between despicable criminal to high
class Yuppie in the blink of an eye to
this point he has been able to keep the
two lives separate and all of his
victims are strangers that would all
change however after a chance encounter
with someone from his past foreign
[Music]
models which ends in a dinner at Nell's
where they're joined by McDermott and
another associate the models are
mind-numbingly dumb they can't even name
a single planet making guesses like the
moon or Comet he ends up going home with
this girl Daisy but before getting in
the cab he runs into his ex-girlfriend
from Harvard Bethany and she invites him
to get lunch sometime since Bateman
always has his mind on his next fix he
interprets this as something more when
he gets back home with Daisy that night
she admits that her ex-boyfriend had
spotted them and couldn't understand why
she was hanging out with a yuppie
another example of the glamor of the
Yuppie lifestyle starting to wear off
after they hook up he tells her she
should leave
think of you
something bad
this doesn't line up with anything we've
come to expect from his character there
have always been certain women who have
been off limits for him because they're
part of his Social Circle but this is
the first time that we've seen him show
pity for someone of course Daisy doesn't
know he's a serial killer and assumes
he's talking about the two of them
getting too emotionally involved so she
leaves and for a short time Bateman
resumes with normal activities like
taking in a Mets game renting videotapes
and purchasing luxurious items that is
until the day that would change
everything his dinner with Paul Owen at
some point he rents an abandoned Loft
building in the Hell's Kitchen
neighborhood of Manhattan in preparation
for his meeting with Paul he also lays
newspapers down over the floor of his
apartment to protect the white stained
oat using the name Marcus halberstam he
makes reservations at Texarkana the
place is mostly dead which Paul mocks
him for but this may be the one time
that the popularity of a restaurant is
not what Patrick is looking for Owen is
really drunk and out of it and he
doesn't offer anything but useless
information about the Fisher account he
keeps changing the topic back to
discussions of material items which
Bateman ironically would do himself
under normal circumstances this scene
certainly came from one of Brett East
and Ellis's own experiences talking to
Wall Street guys in preparation of
writing American Psycho halfway through
the meal Patrick switches from beer to
soda so he can stay sober for what he's
about to do but Paul continues to get
more drunk so drunk that Patrick is able
to convince him to pay the entire check
make him admit how dumb he is and get
him back to the apartment which is
staged for a gruesome scene he takes
some Valium grabs and acts from the
bathroom and puts on a raincoat by this
point Paul is completely inebriated the
whole scene highlights how he isn't
really much different from Patrick
himself in terms of Personality or lack
thereof the main difference is that Paul
has something that Patrick doesn't and
for this Bateman is jealous and vengeful
Paul's Last Words demonstrate his
shallow taste in music just like Bateman
anyway I used to hate Iggy Pop but now
that he's so commercial I like him a lot
better than the ax hits him in
mid-sentence straight in the face it's
thick blade chopping sideways into his
open mouth shutting him up the scene in
the movie is a little bit different
Patrick puts on a Huey Lewis CD and
starts to explain their discography
before or chopping his co-worker to bed
this is a combination of three parts
from the book The Paul Owen death that I
just described the chapter where Bateman
reviews Huey Lewis in the news and a
line that Bateman has during his facial
appointment which he may or may not have
actually said about his desire to wear a
big yellow smiley face mask and then put
on Bobby mcferrin's Don't Worry Be Happy
while transfusing a girl's blood with a
dog anyway he takes Paul's keys and
heads to his apartment not realizing
he's still wearing the spattered
raincoat until he's already in the cab
he ends up destroying it the raincoat
that is in Paul's fireplace he also
changed his Paul's answering machine
message to say that he's gone to London
and since their voices sound similar
Bateman thinks that they'll be
indistinguishable on the phone another
example of him taking advantage of
mistaken identity one of the most often
asked questions in both the movie and
book is if this scene actually happened
because later on an investigator hears
that Paul Owen has actually been seen in
London and his lawyer eventually claims
that he had dinner with Paul in London
perhaps Patrick and Paul did really have
the dinner at Texarkana and Paul told
him that he was planning a London trip
and then Patrick hallucinated the rats
this would not be so different from
Patrick hearing the story about Sean's
awkward double date with Anne and Scott
Smiley but then through his
hallucinations incorporates it into his
own narrative so did he really kill Paul
I have my own theory about this which
I'll come back to when we get to the
next clue later in the story Bateman
packs some suits and travel items from
Paul's belongings into a briefcase and
steals a few things for himself then
leaves back at his own apartment he
throws Owen in a sleeping bag and drags
it downstairs into a taxi and over to
the lofty at rancid he placed his Owen
in the bathtub and pours quick climb
over him a chemical compound which was
thought to help dry out the subject
break it down faster and reduce the
smell Paul is later determined to have
gone missing on the 24th of June in 1989
which obviously doesn't fit our timeline
because we're most likely still in the
first quarter of that year The Cloud of
confusion that hangs over this time
frame it may be intentional because it
adds to the mystery when the detective
eventually comes around and in none of
the dates or accounts of who is with who
that night seemed to add up basically
the inconsistencies around this time can
be considered a watch later in the
evening Patrick can't sleep and Evelyn
calls him complaining that he never
picked her up for dinner that night
which Patrick seems genuinely confused
by and he tells her that they never had
plans and besides he had to return some
videotapes she invites him to go to
dinner the next night instead which he
turns down claiming that he has to work
you practically own that damn company
she moans what work what work do you do
I don't understand thank you Evelyn
that's what I've been saying this whole
time Evelyn also proposes the idea of
going away over the summer to Edgar town
or the Hamptons both are vacation home
destinations in the region which he
actually agrees to but before that
vacation happens Patrick finds himself
in a Paul Smith store to buy a tie for
his brother's upcoming birthday when he
comes across Lewis Caruthers who tries
to start a conversation in Lewis's head
there's still a romantic connection
between the two and he confesses his
love for it Patrick quickly chooses a
tie to buy and exits but Carruthers
catches him as he's trying to hail a cab
begging him to just talk so Patrick
motions his already opened switchblade
in Lewis's Direction and he backs away
into the cab the accountant and Trustee
of Patrick's father both call him up
shortly before Sean's birthday in March
1989 and tell him that Sean is in New
York suggesting that they use this as an
opportunity to find out what Sean is
doing with his life they suggest luring
him into a dinner meeting by indicating
that their mother's health is
deteriorated Patrick doesn't think his
emotionally numb brother will care much
so they devise a plan they'll make it
look like they need to discuss the
allocation of their mother's estate when
choosing a restaurant for this meeting
Patrick thinks to himself that dorsia is
out of the question because it's booked
for at least the next month and Sean
doesn't deserve to go there anyways so
he's astonished when Sean calls him and
tells him to meet at dorsia explaining
he had spoken to the owner and gotten
the table this is the most embarrassing
situation that Patrick could have
imagined as the older one with a career
and list of accomplishments he sees
himself as being above his brother yet
Sean is easily able to get into the
restaurant Patrick has been pining over
for more than a year now Sean shows up
half an hour late and they won't seat
him until his brother's arrival which
Patrick describes as his worst fear
becoming reality Sean continues to get
on Patrick's nerves by ordering the most
expensive combination of items possible
which consists of lobster as both an
appetizer and entree knowing full well
that Patrick is going to be paying the
check then proceeds not to touch any of
his food to make matters worse Patrick
mentions that he needs to meet someone
at Nell's by midnight and Sean downplays
him claiming that Nels isn't that hip
anymore which causes Patrick to change
his story in his insecurity he makes up
a story about going to a trump party and
acts like he knows Donald's personally
at the end of the meal he watches Sean's
eyes and makes sure he's looked at the
check before allowing the waitress to
take it however it's really a lose-lose
situation because Sean gets satisfaction
over wasting his brother's money if that
dinner was bad for Bateman's ego his
next documented appointment would be
catastrophic he is extremely nervous for
his lunch with his Old Harvard
girlfriend Bethany and he even admits
that it's probably because of fear of
rejection based on the hot summer
weather this must take place in summer
1989. before the date he purchases and
reads A trendy short Story collection in
case they run out of things to talk
about he also writes her a poem like he
did during the relationship but it comes
out incredibly crude racist and
derogatory he makes her read it out loud
at the restaurant which is extremely
uncomfortable and she has to laugh it
off as a joke he completely embarrasses
himself for the entire first half of the
meal shaking and twitching his way
through a Litany of cringe-worthy jokes
and Loud outbursts such as his reaction
to the waiter reading the specials you
have I think you mean the restaurant has
I correct him you don't have sun-dried
tomatoes the restaurants does you don't
have the poblano chiles the restaurant
does just you know clarify he overreacts
to everything Bethany says namely when
she tells him she's dating the chef
slash co-owner of dorsia which as you
can imagine has a devastating effect on
him yes my brain does explode and my
stomach bursts open inwardly a [__]
acidic gastric reaction stars and
planets whole galaxies made up entirely
of little white Chef hats race over the
film of my vision he gets
uncharacteristically jealous and
basically berates her for her choice of
partner which confuses her because she
had been under the impression that he
was friends with the guy in college so
perhaps he could have gotten into dorsia
all of this time which is probably even
more infuriating for him he switches
tactics and tries to Vince her that her
boyfriend is gay which doesn't work to
cap it off she insists on paying for
lunch which is extremely emasculating
for him after lunch he invites her back
to his place at first she refuses but
because it's 100 degrees Fahrenheit
outside the air conditioning is broken
at her office and primarily because she
had too many drinks at lunch he is able
to convince her to go home with him big
mistake she tells him he's hung his
David Annika painting upside down which
challenges his supposedly Superior
knowledge of Pop Culture that's strike
one he still can't get over the fact
that she's dating Robert Hall that's
strike two and three apparently he gets
his nail gun and when she sees him
holding it she screams and makes a run
for it but he strikes her with it and
knocks her out then he Nails her fingers
to some wooden boards in the living room
and maces her eyes and places a coat
over her head to drown out some of the
screams after covering her hands and
nails he brings out his handicam so he
can film the rest of the torture which
consists of him undressing her cutting
off her nipple cutting out her tongue
I'm not allowed to say the rest of it
but the point is this is one of his most
brutal offerings yet maybe the worst
part is that she doesn't die until what
I assume is the next day Thursday he
saws her arm off and apparently loses
track of the hand it's a small detail
but if he can lose track of a hand in a
skyrise apartment you'd have to think it
would be pretty easy to lose track of
which events Have and Have Not Really
Happened later on his scrambled brain
continues to get much worse he also
notes that Bethany's lips are bitten off
it's not clear if he did that or if she
did it to herself before long and
Bateman's ability to switch back to a
functional member of society would be
tested as he had to attend a high-end
Wall Street party that evening
[Music]
in the evening after the debacle with
Bethany Bateman attends a party hosted
by Morgan Stanley another financial
company and he tells a colleague he sees
there that he's trying to stay away from
people and avoids speaking to people
entirely either this is a funny excuse
to just not want to talk to this
particular guy or he has so little
self-control at this moment that he
doesn't even trust himself not to kill
the dude I just love all of Bateman's
excuses though after the party he sits
in a cab with McDermott and Courtney
discussing the differences in bottled
waters for like 10 minutes you know I'm
starting to understand why he lost it
now in his head he contemplates how
he'll dispose of Bethany's skeleton and
decides the incinerator down the hall
from his apartment is the best choice
they stop in an ATM but Courtney's card
doesn't work which Patrick is able to
recognize his damage caused by cutting
cocaine though he doesn't always talk
about it I can only imagine how bad his
own drug use has gotten because he
claims this has happened to him in
multiple times when he gets home that
night he examines Bethany's body and
smashes her jaw open with her own arm
until her head caves that weekend a hard
body told him that rap is the only thing
she listens to so after beating the [__]
out of her he went to the record store
and picked up ninety dollars worth of
rap CDs the next Monday he was sitting
in his office at 8pm doing the crossword
and listening to these CDs trying to
Fathom their popularity I can actually
relate to Bateman here I try to Fathom
the popularity of rap music just about
every time I hear it although he usually
just likes anything that's hip and Hip
Hop literally has hip in the name I
think the reason that he doesn't like
rap is because it's not the right kind
of Hit the hip that he wants to be
associated with consists of expensive
suits expensive restaurants and classy
bars and clubs the music he likes seems
to be high production value pop and pop
rock rapping the 80s was rapidly gaining
popularity but it was still far less
glamorous and featured themes such as
life in the ghetto being a gangster and
even advocating for the poor definitely
not Bateman's scene however despite him
probably being upset about rap he's
relieved to hear that Evelyn is in
Boston for the week and his favorite guy
Donald Trump makes an appearance on his
favorite show the Patty winter show this
does seem like a believe Patty winter
segment however the next segment of the
show is about women who have been
tortured that one is probably a
hallucination and an indicator that
Patrick's personal account of events is
not too reliable during this part of the
story he did have dinner plans with
Madison gray and David Campion that
evening but at the last minute he
discovered that Lewis Carruthers would
be joining them so he canceled and
decided to ask his secretary Jean out to
dinner instead he tells her to choose
any restaurant she'd like and she
chooses dorsia not wanting to admit that
he can't get them in he calls the
restaurant and when the maitre d
inevitably tells him that they're booked
he acts as if he really did get the
reservation he didn't give a name they
know me Patrick is more tense than ever
when calling dorsia he can casually
dispose of bodies with relative ease but
getting dorsia reservations will always
rattle him when they arrive he looks
over the podium into the reservation
book and finds the name of a couple with
a table at 9pm his plan works but even
after they're seated he's so nervous
that the words in the menu look like
hieroglyphics to him and for good reason
eventually the couple whose table he
stole shows up he thanks to himself that
if the couple was less attractive or
less well-dressed he might have at least
been able to bribe his way into keeping
the table but since everyone in the
whole restaurant looks like models he
has no leverage and he's forced to leave
with Gene Bateman is humiliated but Gene
is laughing and skipping down the street
she thinks he's funny and spontaneous
and Patrick is surprised he's not used
to going out with women who would
appreciate the fun experience of trying
to steal a dinner reservation the women
that he usually goes out with would
judge him on his inability to get the
reservation they end up at Arcadia with
an A and are one of only five tables
filled there it's not hip but for Gene
it doesn't really matter and at the end
of the night she invites him up for a
drink this is an opportunity for him to
satiate his bloodlust but something
stops him and he makes up weird excuses
about why he can't go up he wants to go
home and watch David Letterman but not
on cable realizing this doesn't make
sense he reverts to his tried and true
excuse to get out of anything he's gotta
go return some videotapes as he says
goodbye to Gene he imagines the scene as
a movie I almost hear the swelling of an
orchestra can almost hallucinate the
camera panning low around us fireworks
bursting in slow motion overhead the 70
millimeter image of her lips parting to
the subsequent murmur of I want you in
Dolby Sam throughout the day there are
signs that he really may have feelings
for Gene and maybe that's why he wants
to protect her by not going upstairs he
knows her life could be in danger if he
does as the hottest months of summer
roll by he has intense dreams about
vivisection the practice of cutting open
Live subjects yeah okay Bateman go ahead
and blame that one on the heat one
morning in August he's paid a visit at
his office by detective Donald Kimball
in the movie Kimball is played by Willem
Dafoe but in the book Kimball is the
same age as Bateman just use your
imagination throughout the interrogation
he plays it extremely cool a stark
contrast to his behavior at lunch with
Bethany he even allows Kimball to smoke
inside his office whereas he had loudly
voiced his disgust for the patron
smoking in the restaurant Kimball has
been hired by Meredith Powell to
investigate The Disappearance of Paul
Owen supposedly Paul had been spotted in
London but unsurprisingly the witness
who saw him there may have been
confusing him with somebody else even
while trying to clear his name Bateman
can't help but make up a few lies to
tarnish Owen's reputation then when
asked about the last time he was with
Owen he concocts a story about how they
went to go see a new musical called oh
Africa Brave Africa his lies could
easily be disproven but Bateman believes
he's Untouchable because of his money
and he may be right because none of this
ever comes back to bite him it helps
that Kimball doesn't actually suspect
him in the first place he's just
covering his bases he asks where Bateman
was the night that Paul disappeared and
he spouts off something about a date
with a girl named Veronica Kimball
realizes this doesn't match up with the
info he's already collected apparently
the United Paul's disappearance he was
scheduled to have dinner with Marcus
halberstam as we would expect because
Bateman made the reservation under
halverstam's name naturally the real
Marcus halberstam denied this and said
he was with five other guys that night
one of which was Bateman himself this
whole mistaken identity thing has gotten
so out of control that Bateman is given
an alibi at a dinner he'd never even
attended or maybe he did attend and his
mind is so out of sorts that he only
thinks he killed Paul Owen to
demonstrate how scrambled his mind is
during this very conversation he's
thinking about a hundred different
things a minute Bateman does offer some
gossip telling him that Meredith is now
dating someone named Brock Thompson if
you're paying attention this is very
different from the last time we saw
Meredith which was at the Christmas
party eight months ago at the time she
was dating Paul Owen I wonder if Patrick
and Evelyn stealing their limo and
Evelyn taking Meredith's Christmas gift
contributed to the breakup seeing as how
relationships in these circles seem to
hinge on access to material Goods
apparently Meredith is looking for Paul
not because she is concerned about him
or cares about him but because he owes
her money if we are to consider the
possibility that Bateman did not
actually kill Owen this provides some
incentive as to why he might be hiding
out in London by the way Meredith seems
to be a pretty big psycho in her own
rights if you're keeping track at home
she dates price who dumps her someone
named Richard Cunningham Van Patten then
Paul Owen and finally this Brock
Thompson in any event Kimball doesn't
seem to suspect Foul Play and ironically
he thinks Paul is the one who went nuts
after Kimball leaves Bateman gets his
phone checked for wiretaps and he
actually runs into Meredith and Brock
that week she doesn't even bring up Paul
Owen once soon after he begins an affair
with a new girl named Jeanette Jeanette
is an interesting case at first I
thought she was just a new girl that
Patrick was going to prey on but I
gradually started to wonder if she was
almost more of an alter ego or fantasy
version of the secretary Gene for
example when Patrick is being normal he
sees Gene but when he's having his vile
fantasies he imagines himself out with
the jeans it wouldn't be so different
from the whole Arcadia versus Arcadia
confusion and it also makes me wonder if
there's something to the fact that
Patrick earlier on dated a girl named
Patricia and there are even some
character names that are just slightly
changed in the movie adaptation Paul
Owen is Paul Allen Timothy price is
Timothy Bryce Evelyn Richards is Evelyn
Williams Jeanette never interacts with
any of the other characters with one
exception in October Patrick
accidentally double books a date and
Evelyn and Jeanette end up at the same
restaurant looking for him and Evelyn
gets pissed she knows who Jean is but
they might not have ever met in person
so this might be another one of those
questions that the author did not intend
on being answered this is also the part
of the book where we have to question
almost everything that Bateman says so
keep that in mind going forward he's
continuing on a steady trajectory
towards complete Insanity he spends the
rest of the summer of 89 doing all the
stuff he usually does to reflect this
The Paddy winter show in this era
consists of repeats his nightly
bloodlust overflows into the daytime
until finally he asks Evelyn to go with
him on a getaway to The Hamptons she has
the key to Tim Price's vacation house
for some reason so that's where they
stay at first this is actually a pretty
normal couple's vacation they did things
like tennis windsurfing and breakfast in
bed then things get weird he bought her
a dog which she named NutraSweet and fed
dietetic chocolate truffles maybe the
dog is imaginary because dogs definitely
can't eat chocolate as time went on
everything started to feel dull again
and Patrick's weird Behavior would
return he found himself roaming beaches
digging up crabs and eating sand one
morning he microwaved and ate a
jellyfish then fed the leftovers to the
dog Evelyn's old Behavior also crept
back up she became obsessed with her
beauty appointments traveling back to
the city more and more often to have
them done Bateman longs to kill again so
he takes advantage of her time away and
uses it to drown neutral sweet she
doesn't even seem to remember that she
even had a dog when she gets back so it
probably never existed but maybe Evelyn
is just that self-obsessed Bateman knows
it's time to leave the Hamptons when he
finds himself standing over their bed
one night with an ice pick gripped in
his fist waiting for her to open her
eyes somehow he comes to his senses
before she wakes up on September 3rd one
day before Labor Day that year they
would return to Manhattan by helicopter
later that month Patrick has dinner with
a model named Elizabeth and two of her
friends afterwards they took a limousine
to Nells and he left her there so he
could go pick up Christy the blonde
Corner girl from the previous year she
is hesitant because she got so dinged up
last time but he UPS his offer so that
it's too good to pass up I'm gonna make
him an awful again her make her an offer
that she can't refuse he promises that
nothing like last time would be repeated
technically not wrong because he would
go way further first he forces Christy
to wait in the limo as he goes back into
Nell's and enjoys drinks with the others
he's treating her like a pads because
that's probably what he thinks of her he
and Elizabeth don't emerge from Nells
until 2 30 in the morning they go back
to Bateman's apartment where he tries to
convince the two girls to hook up
Elizabeth is against the idea until the
Ecstasy he slipped into her wine kicks
in Patrick directs the scene again and
eventually joins in himself he and
Elizabeth tie Christie up on the futon
but Bateman gets too hungry and uh bites
off a slice of pepperoni if you catch my
drift soon Elizabeth has gained enough
awareness to sense danger and she's
running for her life out of the bedroom
but she slips allowing Patrick to get
her in the neck with a butcher knife
next he tries to recharge Christy using
a pair of jumper cables connected to a
battery I'll let you figure out how
those were connected between that and
the array of matches he drops on her she
gets more fried than the calamari at
dorsia still she manages to survive
until he mashes her up with a pair of
pliers laughing as he does so somehow
although it does not seem possible
Patrick's mental stability continues to
worsen after this plus he's nearly
driven to do the unthinkable after
another confrontation with Louis
Caruthers
Bateman resorts to seeing a psychiatrist
but it's unclear exactly what goes on in
these sessions we do know that he
doesn't admit his murders to the
psychiatrist eventually he spills
everything to his lawyer but that's not
until much later one Sunday afternoon
after having brunch with Christy's
remains he's out shopping at Barney's
after being chased out of the ladies
shoe department for making a scene and
he has the sense that he's being
followed and discovers it's Lewis
Carothers who pretends that it's a
random encounter Patrick tries to ignore
him refusing to look him in the eyes as
Carruthers begs for his attention he
claims he's transferring to the Arizona
Branch because he can't bear to be
around Patrick and has the idea that
Patrick is hiding his true feelings
towards him Lewis starts crying and
making a huge scene which draws the
attention of a security guard Bateman
threatens to slit his throats but this
does no good because Carothers cries
that if they can't be together he'd
prefer to die Bateman feels his sanity
starting to fade and it eventually gets
to the point that he kicks Lewis in the
face and tells him to Face Reality which
seems to at least get Lewis to stop
whining as Autumn progresses Bateman's
homicidal compulsion goes up and down
he's sleeping in 20-minute intervals
likely due to the Clash of substances in
his system one day he roamed Central
Park Zoo he sees a sign warning guests
not to throw coins which can kill the
animals if swallowed so he tosses a
handful of them into the seal tank when
nobody's looking he believes it's the
audience's enjoyment of the seals that
bothers him not the seals themselves the
bar for what triggers him is getting
lower and lower at the bird exhibit he
perceives some kind of telepathic
communication from a snowy owl Huey
Lewis is sport is a Flawless Masterpiece
you say oh really then in the penguin
habitat he crouches behind a trash can
where a kid is throwing away a candy
wrapper and stabs him in throats then
mingles into the crowd and watches the
reaction when the kid's mother discovers
what has become of her child he falsely
claims to be a doctor and basically
holds the child and does nothing until
police arrive after all of this despite
this probably being the riskiest thing
he's done he feels unsatisfied because
he's taking a life that doesn't have
much history and will affect fewer
people as opposed to taking someone in
their Prime who has friends a career a
spouse and a past this is a obviously
debatable because I think a lot of
people are going to be more upset about
something happening to a kid due to
genetic instincts that drive us to
protect our young so this may be another
example of him being out of touch with
human emotion he ends up just standing
there and watching everything unfold as
he slowly Blends back into the crowd
then walks away even Bateman's
appearances at the office start to
become more sporadic it seems the only
thing he wants to do is work out and get
restaurant reservations then cancel them
he's mindlessly feeding his addiction
his apartment begins to reek of brain
pulp which he had scooped out of
Christy's head so he uses Paul Owen's
apartment to host two escort girls who
he tortures with mace a nail gun and
nail scissors a steak Knife acid and an
array of power tools I guess he felt a
little self-conscious when they started
complimenting Owen's nice apartment
closer than your other apartment and
oh it's not that nice since he has other
plans later he goes about his day as
normal after this almost as if killing
gives him a reset on his ability to
function in society in mid-october he
gets a bunch of new deliveries to his
apartment one of which is a replacement
for his David Annika painting which he's
now decided to sell this was the
painting that Bethany had laughed at him
for hanging upside down more evidence of
his yearning for her approval even after
her supposed death he's on the phone
when he hears a huge rat emerged from
his toilet and steal a leftover pizza
when I made the Chuck E cheese video I
never thought I'd be using this clip
again actually he specifies it's a giant
rat so let's use this one instead he's
on a lot of Halcyon the sleep medication
that Wards off Total Insanity so the rat
doesn't bother him as much as it should
he just buys an extra large mousetrap
and spends the night in his dad's old
Suite in the Carlyle the next morning he
finds the rat alive in the Trap and
barricades it in the sink with plans to
use it to freak out girls though freak
out is probably an understatement as you
will soon find out and that brings us to
another night this is probably my
favorite book chapter that isn't in the
movie because of its chaotic
Ridiculousness but it also gave me an
epiphany about what's really going on
with Patrick Bateman and I think it
holds the answer to what happened to
Paul Owen so let's break it down it
starts at 6 30 PM with Bateman and
McDermott discussing their reservations
for a restaurant called 1500. we find
out that Hamlin wants to join but he
wants to eat somewhere else but he
doesn't have a backup place in mind and
he wants to invite Lewis Carothers
Bateman obviously says no Then tries to
back out altogether then he changes his
mind realizing that Hamlin might be able
to supply them with drugs and Lewis
won't be making it after all so
McDermott goes to cancel the reservation
at 1500 and Hamlin goes to make a new
reservation at Zeus bar while he's on
the other line they realize zeuspar
might be hard to get into and brainstorm
a backup plan then Jeanette calls on the
other line upset and Bateman invites her
to meet them at Zeus bar back in the
main call they couldn't get into zeuspar
so McDermott makes a 9 pm reservation at
Cactus Jeanette calls again and he gets
confused and tells her they'll be at
Zeus bar back in the main call Van
Patton joins and he's going to go to
dinner too then Evelyn calls on the
other line already aware of their plans
at Cactus thanks to Hamlin's girlfriend
spilling the beans he tells her that
it's actually a zoo Spar that they're
going to which again is incorrect he
returns to the main call where they
remind him that he's already invited
Jeanette so bringing Evelyn might be a
problem Van Patten suggests canceling
Jeanette and inviting Evelyn to zeuspar
at 9 30 where again they do not have
reservations Bateman doesn't want to see
Evelyn so he tries to get Hamlin's
girlfriend to invite Evelyn to go
somewhere else she refuses because she
now has one-on-one plans with Hamlin so
he just invites both of them to go with
the main group unable to remember if
they're going to Cactus or Zoo Spar Van
Patton no longer wants Mexican food and
I can't remember who made the
reservation Van Patten suggests a
different restaurant called 1969 but
when he goes to make the reservation
it's full it's now 8 30. they continue
to argue for another hour so it's 9 30.
they've been on the phone for three
hours this includes them canceling the
cactus reservation and remaking it and
baymen getting confused and canceling a
non-existent table at zeuspar 1969 is
now closed 1500 is now closed McDermott
remakes another Cactus reservation then
Bateman gets a call from Evelyn who is
already at Cactus with Jeanette and
she's pissed he tells her they'll be
going there shortly but then the Men
start talking about something else and
it's unclear if they'll ever actually go
to Cactus or if they just continue to
improvise their plans for the entire
night the key takeaway for all of this
for me is how Bateman easily loses track
of who's going and where they have
reservations we even see him start to
invent reservations in his head cannon
that were never actually made so if
Bateman's brain can be disoriented that
easily who is to say that he wouldn't
also lack the ability to keep track of
who he actually killed and who he just
fantasized about killing now in order
for this to be possible it's very likely
that he does actually kill sometimes but
he has these situational awareness not
to get himself caught in the moment so
if he's with an important co-worker like
Paul Owen for example he'll create a
fantasy story in his head he knows Paul
is going to London so he fantasizes
about killing Paul and making it look
like he's in London but looking back at
it shortly after he just remembers the
fantasy and comes to believe that that's
what he really did as for the other
victims it's very hard to determine if
any of them are real or not because the
insanity is taking a bigger and bigger
hold on him for example that month he
films himself eating a girl's brain and
the Patty winter show is about a machine
that lets people talk to the dead his
next victim is one of his most
disturbing he's foaming at the mouth and
duffs are insides full of cheese then he
sticks a habit Trail into her you know
those Tunnels for pet rodents to run in
he then unleashes the giant rat who he's
been starving for the last five days and
it's Bon Appetit at the end he cuts her
in two with a chainsaw which goes
through her so fast that she's alive for
a moment to see him remove her legs from
the rest of her body he places her femur
and Jawbone to bake in the oven I would
say that Halloween came early this year
but for Patrick it seems to come early
every day of every year speaking of
which for Halloween the office has a
Halloween party and Bateman goes as a
mass murderer using a combination of
real and fake blood nobody knows any
better as usual this seems to give him
that mental reset and he's able to
function normally for a short while in
early November he describes this feeling
as being halfway capable of being
cheerful so he accepts Evelyn's
invitation to go out to dinner and while
the dinner did manage to be halfway
normal by his standards the same could
not be said about dessert that morning
he stole a urinal cake and covered it
with chocolate syrup and packaged it in
a fancy box he pays the waiter to
present the dessert at the end of the
meal as if he had called earlier in
order did special and he sees to it that
her water glass is empty when it arrives
as Evelyn eats it she tries to hide her
gag by saying it was just mintier than
she suspected this could truly only work
on someone like Evelyn who favors the
value of the food she's eating over how
it actually tastes she also doesn't want
to do anything to upset Patrick because
of what she's about to ask next she
wants him to make a firm commitment for
marriage Patrick realizes that the eye
she's had on him over the last two years
is rooted in something closer to Greed
than adoration and explains to her
what's truly important to him I need to
engage in homicidal behavior on a
massive scale cannot be corrected but I
have no other way to fulfill my needs no
huge surprise but she doesn't get it and
thinks he's asking her to get breast
implants again which is a hilarious
little detail in its own right he tells
Evelyn that it's over between them he
doesn't want to be weighed down with a
commitment at 27 years old according to
his earlier comments he would have
recently just turned 28 so again he's
unable to keep track of time not even
realizing his own age it takes a while
for Evelyn to understand that he's
serious about this breakup but when she
does she becomes hysterical although
Bateman doesn't enjoy her suffering as
much as he thought he would as she's
crying and begging to know what will
make him stay with her his mind just
wanders to a hundred other things he
tells her that because of her Outburst
he will not be paying for the meal and
he leaves free from the confines of his
relationship he moves on to try even
Wilder things that would make his
previous Adventures look minuscule he
would make the most of the limited time
remaining in the era of the Yuppie the
1980s were coming to a close
[Music]
I tried for close to an hour to explain
what happens in the chapter entitled
tries to cook and eat girl without
getting myself age restricted or heated
off this platform and came up with close
to nothing if you need the details go
read the book yourself I'm just gonna
skip right to the analysis part at first
Bateman kept his vices relatively closed
off from one another then we saw a
certain bedroom activities combined with
certain sharp object related activities
now we are seeing his love of dining
thrown into the mix as well then he does
all of that while watching videos just
like the average cz's World viewer I'm
kidding so he's combining more and more
of these addictions his hobbies are
becoming one big conglomerate activity
my takeaway is that he's no longer able
to get the response he used to from
doing them individually so now in order
to get that bigger hit he's got to stack
them he also considers for maybe the
first time if he'll ever spend time in
prison he can't tell if he's clicking
anything correctly because he's never
cooked before and he's crying too hard
another new development as far as we
know he's now carrying firearms around
keeping them in his locker when he goes
to the gym and bringing them on his
daily errands like returning videos ATM
withdrawals and violating NYU students a
new Patty winter centers around a man
who set his daughter on fire while she
was giving birth in addition to the
Patty winter show segment serving as an
insanity indicator some of his meals
seem to do the same he goes to dinner
with Associates and they all order shark
perhaps that is fitting because Bateman
is seeing everyone around him as
potential prey nap this is the craziest
he gets this is the absolute bottom
after midnight that night he shoots a
saxophonist performing on an empty
street corner but his silencer doesn't
work and he fails to notice a police
squad car traveling behind him at first
he tries to walk away casually then it
breaks into Iran the cop car takes off
after him so he jumps into a taxi and
orders the cavi to drive apparently just
expecting that the guy will obey him
just because he's so used to bossing
around a blue collar workers the guy
panics so Bateman shoots him and Jacks
the car losing control into a Korean
Deli and knocking over the cashier a cop
charges from seemingly nowhere and
knocks him to the sidewalk and the two
wrestle for Bateman's gun but while all
this is going on all he can think about
is that there should be music playing
because it reminds him of an action
scene in a movie it's very reminiscent
of the end of his dinner with a gene
that summer he gets the upper hand on
the cop and shoots him twice in the head
but as he's trying to get away more cop
cars show up in an alley and it turns
into a huge firefight in the romance
scene with Gene Patrick hallucinated
something cinematic then eventually came
back down to earth so if you haven't
figured it out yet that is probably
what's happening here because this whole
Manhattan Chase is pretty unrealistic
especially when this happens
he runs off to Wall Street and noticing
he's in a more affluent area tries to
steal several Porsches unsuccessfully so
like an action hero he somersaults over
an embankment to get to his office
building another more clear-cut sign
that he's in a Hallucination is that he
sees his office building and the lights
go off floor by floor as he approaches
however he realizes that this is his old
building before his company moved this
may be an extension of the theme of
characters misidentifying one another
now expanded to include buildings which
is actually more understandable earning
the Midnight Oil Mr Smith
foreign
to the night Watchman and to a janitor
that happened to be watching Patrick
goes to his real office signs in with
his real night Watchman and goes up to
his office and that's when the calmness
returns he thinks he may really be in
some trouble this time and calls his
lawyer Harold Karns but gets the machine
he leaves the message sobbing as he
details everything he's done 30 40 maybe
a hundred murders a helicopter Combs the
area with a Searchlight but just like
that Knight turns today and it's morning
Bateman describes this as some kind of
optical illusion though it's probably
just his psychosis however his voicemail
message to Karns would eventually be
acknowledged until then he returns to
the real world he takes Jeanette to
dinner at deck chairs stays home to
watch Patty Winters and then sleeps with
Courtney while Lewis is in Atlanta one
week before their wedding Courtney seems
depressed and tries to talk to Patrick
about something but he brushes her off
telling her she's gonna marry Louis and
that there's nothing to talk about
whatever she was going to say she keeps
to herself during a dinner at Smith and
wolenski with Craig McDermott Bateman's
mind wanders to his cousin from
Washington who recently better girl's
earlobes off if this is real it's likely
that Bateman's condition is hereditary
or at the very least mental illness runs
in the family we know his mother is
institutionalized for something which
we'll get to and his little brother
definitely exhibits a lot of sociopathic
personality traits himself McDermott
always wanted to criticize one's food
choices called Bateman a raving Maniac
for not ordering the hashbrowns been at
PNP too long he mutters another night
after seeing a musical with Jeanette he
describes another strange food order
Eagle carpaccia which comes with a weird
gazpacho containing raw chicken
something that no restaurant would ever
serve for health and safety reasons
except maybe one good because it turns
out I forgot to cook that chicken unlike
Evelyn who talks too much Jeanette
hardly seems to speak at all throughout
the day she keeps sighing and
threatening to light her cigarette in
the non-smoking section she drinks six
champagne cures and he even considers
her behavior unsettling causing black
thoughts to form and expand in his head
it's almost like Jeanette is a
reflection of Bateman's desires Evelyn
annoyed him she talked too much said the
wrong things had the wrong intro address
and was resistant to almost everything
he did Jeanette on the other hand seems
to go along with anything and the more
disturbing Bateman's headspace gets the
more Disturbed he is by Jeanette's
Behavior he even tells her to get a
water when she's thirsty instead of more
champagne the following month Patrick
has a rare visit with his mother in the
mental institution Sandstone at least I
assume this takes place in December
because his mom asks him what he wants
for Christmas Patrick is under the
impression that it's mid-april I'm not
really sure either of them can be
trusted to correctly relay the dates
however the previous events definitely
took place in November Courtney told
Patrick to have a nice Thanksgiving and
we've not yet reached the chapter titled
end of the 1980s at first it's unclear
why he visits his mom he doesn't seem to
care about her at all but throughout the
encounter he takes note of all the
things he's bought her it's likely that
he's visiting to give her gifts another
win that he can hold over Sean the next
time we hear from Patrick he claims that
161 days have passed since his night at
Paul's apartment with the two escort
girls that puts us somewhere in February
or March of the year 1990. that is if
you want to believe that he has his
bearings when he says 100 61 days have
passed I'm going to take his word for it
this time because it's raining and rain
during March in New York makes sense
plus we don't really have anything else
to go on with no word of any bodies
being discovered in any newspaper he
gets curious and starts asking peers if
they heard about two mutilated women in
Paul Owen's apartment which is
absolutely hilarious to inquire about
he's practically begging to get caught
but nobody will throw a suspicious
glance in his direction of course given
my theory that Paul's death was only a
fantasy he never would have acquired
access to Paul's apartment which means
he never would have brought the girls
there that was also a fantasy this is
backed up by the fact that when he
checks back in 161 days later the
building looks different and the keys no
longer fit maybe because they never did
a doorman lets him in anyway and he goes
up to an apartment in the midst of a
real estate showing he notices the
blinds are different but the furniture
is the same and there are bouquets of
flowers all over the apartment which he
can smell could this be proof that he
actually did Kill Paul and the realtor
is using the flowers to cover the stench
left behind by the bodies of the escorts
or is that overthinking it it is normal
to want the apartment you're trying to
sell to smell good the realtor tells him
that Paul does not live there but she
realizes something that causes her to
tighten up perhaps most suspiciously
this happens
we saw the ad and the times
the times there was no ad in the time
the time I think you should go now this
is the most compelling evidence that the
murders aren't actually real however I'd
make the counter argument that Patrick's
behavior is just unnerving in general
and she probably felt uncomfortable with
him just showing up out of the blue and
snooping around she tells him not to
come back and watches him all the way
back to the door in the elevator the
smell of roses is overpowering which
symbolizes Patrick seriously feeling the
paranoia of getting caught for the first
time but that doesn't stop him from
slicing up three more women and
according to him storing their private
parts in his gym locker the chapter I
mentioned earlier entitled end of the
1980s actually takes place several
months into the new year he says the
anniversary of Elvis's death was a month
ago and Elvis died on August 16th so
theoretically it's mid-september as
always there's a very good possibility
that Patrick has no idea what the date
is but he does say on multiple occasions
that this is September and the cool
sunny weather does match up as for the
chapter title he might not be saying
this is literally where 1980 ends as in
like New Year's Eve but this might be
the first moment where it stops fueling
like the 1980s much like like how I
always say that the 1990s ended in 2003
with the release of hey ya he's now
having horrible dreams where rich people
in lavish settings are massacred in
tragic ways he's no longer able to
distinguish a Dream from reality as
evidenced by the ratio of brutal
accidents he sees randomly walking
around in the city he meets Jean for
lunch near Tower Records and they seem
to be dating that as they discuss plans
for dinner he mentions that he's on a
diet Gene tells him that he already
looks great to which he replies you can
always be thinner a call back to
Evelyn's you can always be in better
shape line way back in chapter one
somehow it seems that he's still holding
a grudge against Evelyn Gene tells him
they don't have to go out to dinner if
it's going to ruin his willpower and he
admits he's not very good at controlling
it anyways which has got to be the
understatement of the year over coffee
he tells her a story about a Wall Street
guy he saw marking up a wall in the
bathroom who wrote kill all yuppies
earlier I talked about how the Yuppie
lifestyle was already growing out of
fashion in the eyes of the crowd at Club
sure Noble and now it appears that even
Wall Street people are sick of The Fad
if the date is September 1990 that means
we're only seven months away from that
yup dumb obituary being published in
Time Magazine Bayman has modeled his
entire lifestyle around being hip and
Rich but that's about to go out of style
which can't be good for his mental
stability as usual Gene doesn't seem to
care about any of that she tells him
that they need to talk about something
and anyone who's ever heard those words
knows what comes next she thinks she's
in love with him and he gives her very
mixed signals in return usually he's
much more directed with women which
could mean that he really does feel
something for Gene but just doesn't know
how to deal with that Gene is worried
that he's disappointed in her for
confessing her love but he secretly
thinks that he could never be
disappointed because he no longer finds
anything worth looking forward to her
reasons for liking him are also
completely off the mark she sees him as
someone concerned with others mysterious
considerate and shy summertime is Gene
he explains the line separating
appearance what you see and reality
which you don't become well blurred he's
very aware of the illusionment he's been
living in over the last couple years and
although he seems to be giving her the
cold shoulder at first he has this
realization that this could be a crucial
moment in his life but for the first
time jeans seems stronger and less
controllable than before which he's
attracted to and thinks to himself why
not end up with her well before he could
consider that there would be one major
roadblock
[Music]
foreign
after he turns 29 in October Patrick
Bateman gets some news from Jeanette
she's pregnant something that's kind of
surprising because he's been very
particular about contraception in the
past on December 20th they argue about
if they should carry forward with the
pregnancy which results in jeannette's
getting a black eye the next day he gets
his way and Jeanette is sobbing the
entire car ride to the abortion clinic
according to Patrick this is the fifth
time he's aborted a pregnancy with all
of that being said I can't say with much
confidence that any of this actually
happened because the Paddy winter show
that day featured an interview with
Bigfoot this is the last time we see
Jeanette so maybe the abortion is more
symbolic an abortion is immediate and
irreversible and he's ending his
relationship with her in an immediate
irreversible way once again he
experiments with new ways to hurt her
that don't include physical abuse he
buys a bunch of baby items a doll a
rattle a teething ring and a stuffed
polar bear and leaves them in the back
of the limo for her to find when she
gets back he's about to leave on a
flight to Aspen that day and Jeanette is
going to be out of the country when he
returns he makes it very clear that he
doesn't plan on seeing her again he says
Jeanette should be okay she has her
whole life in front of her that is if
she doesn't run into me if you want to
interpret Jeanette as a fantasy version
of Gene this means he's decided to focus
his efforts on being with the real Gene
if you want to interpret Jeanette as
just a separate woman then this means
Patrick is just ending his relationship
with her Bayman gets back from Aspen in
January 1991 and finally makes use of
his piano for the first time or at least
the piano strings which he uses on a
couple of victims the second week of
February is especially unhinged he
starts drinking his own urine sleeping
under his futon flossing his gums to
bleeding and he's nearly caught trying
to send a girl's heart to her mother at
FedEx he also doesn't seem entirely done
torturing Evelyn because he sends her a
box of flies with a note saying he never
wants to see her again and to go on a
diet LOL meanwhile his relationship with
jeans seems to have blossomed on
Valentine's Day he shows affection in
the only way he knows how by having a
bunch of expensive stuff delivered to
her apartment the shipment also includes
hundreds of white roses the white rose
is said to symbolize loyalty Purity and
innocence I don't really know where that
comes from but if you look up White Rose
symbolism a bunch of websites seem to
agree on this fact of course none of
these characteristics apply to Bateman
whatsoever is he attracted to these
qualities in gene or does he have a
desire to clean up his act time will
tell that morning he also has his maid
come in and clean up a bloody mess in
his apartment I'm guessing this is not
real or maybe this mate is just
incredibly subservient it wouldn't be
the first time that he hired someone to
clean up after his Carnage he reads
various articles in the post such as
three people who disappeared aboard a
yacht found hacked up and frozen in ice
and a maniac going around poisoning one
liter bottles of Evian this is a lot
like the first chapter where Bateman and
price read about two people who
disappeared on a yacht among a slew of
other problems with their City both of
these chapters take place on a
pseudo-holiday April Fool's Day and
Valentine's Day respectively we see this
a lot in any traditional story structure
it's called the Dano ma or falling
action after the climax where things go
back to normal usually this happens
after some kind of resolution with the
main character but Bateman stands out
here because nothing has been resolved
with him and speaking of a return to the
beginning Timothy price resurfaces for
the first time since his disappearance
in the tunnel at tunnel nightclub almost
four years ago now early on I discussed
Bateman following in his footsteps it's
rumored that price went to rehab and it
makes me wonder if Bateman will do the
same at some point or maybe he already
has price visits him in his office and
has a smudge on his forehead that
Bateman assumes is a hallucination
however in 1991 the Catholic holiday Ash
Wednesday was the day before Valentine's
Day so it's likely that this smudge was
actually just leftover Ash Ash Wednesday
is the day that Catholics give up
something that they love maybe price has
decided to give up his use of drugs when
asked where he's been he says that he's
been back for a while but he moved
companies a call back to his complaints
about his pay in the first chapter one
day after feeding portions of brain
matter to dogs in the park he passes by
Al the hobo that he supposedly blinded
in 1988. he's holding a sign that reads
Vietnam Vets blinded in Vietnam this
would suggest that he was already blind
and Bateman's assault on him was just
imaginary however when Bateman goes up
to him and Whispers you never were in
Vietnam the man pisses himself and begs
him not to hurt him we're constantly
being shown conflicting evidence towards
the validity of Patrick's outbursts to
top it all off the Patty winter show
that day features a Cheerio being
interviewed for close to an hour and
Patrick buys a chocolate bar that he
claims has a bone in it one evening
Bateman goes to a new club called
world's end with Jean and another woman
named Nina when he finally runs into his
lawyer Harold Carnes the two have not
spoken since Bateman's unhinged
voicemail confession when he brings it
up it becomes clear that Karns has like
many others mistaken him with someone
named Davis and he thinks the whole
thing is a joke he doesn't even believe
that Bateman would be capable of killing
Paul Owen or even picking up an escort
because he sees him as too much of a
goody goody Karns thinks that Evelyn was
the one to dump him and when Bateman
insists that the murders really did
happen he refuses to believe because I
had dinner with Paul Allen twice in
London just 10 days ago is it possible
given all the mistaken identity in the
story that Karns actually had dinner
with somebody else sure but as I stated
I don't believe that Paul is really dead
to calm down Patrick's takes a Halcyon
he also tries to get Nina's number while
Gina's in the bathroom downstairs even
though he seems to recognize that Gene
is special to him he still has not
departed from his adulterous ways be
next week he reluctantly has a decadent
breakfast with his former dealer who got
a real job and another colleague instead
of his mind wandering to the usual
degenerate stuff he's into he thinks
about helping America's schools and
getting tickets to see sting in three
Penny Opera due to this very strange
behavior for him because helping schools
sounds like something he preached about
to Virtue signal to his friends way back
at the beginning rather than something
that he'd actually be interested in
doing and not long ago he thought that
Jeanette deserved to get an abortion
because she thought sting was cool is
Patrick starting to gain some
sensibility back he finds himself
reading the paper as he listens to his
Walkman in a taxi just like he did back
in chapter one but the cab driver keeps
looking at him funny then the driver
locks the doors and speeds down the
highway accusing him of being the guy
who killed a fellow cabbie named Sally
this could be the driver that Bateman
took out before that big man Manhattan
chase scene perhaps parts of that scene
were real ironically he's finally been
correctly identified and it's by a
nobody the cab driver is holding a gun
and robs him of his Rolex watch his
wallet and his expensive sunglasses
knowing that he can go to the police
otherwise the driver will just rat him
out there is no reward for turning in
Bateman so he's able to steal his stuff
without repercussion this is the first
consequence that Patrick has ever paid
for his actions and it isn't much
however he does lose his expensive
material possessions which are part of
what makes him feel powerful before
speeding off the cab driver calls him a
yuppie scumbag which makes Bateman choke
up a sob he's supposed to have power
over blue collar people like a cab
driver all in all the emotional damage
to Bateman's ego probably ends up being
the worst part of this ordeal for him
his insurance pays for a new gold Rolex
but his mind continues to deteriorate he
believes his ATM machine is speaking to
him with weird messages and a park bench
followed him home for six blocks and
spoke to him he spends the morning
making a necklace out of a girl's
vertebrae and wearing it to watch adults
tapes but he still returns to his usual
debauchery one Friday a group of guys
including price and McDermott Goodrich
and Farrell go back to the first bar
that we ever saw Bateman go to Harry's
and American Psycho comes to a close
with the guys debating where to get
dinner reservations as everyone bombards
Bateman with questions of men's fashion
and other useless topics that he's made
himself an expert in he wonders if he's
become a fitness junkie certainly an
ironic thing for an actual junkie to be
worried about his favorite group is now
the Talking Heads it's a relatively
normal topic on the Patty winter show
and does economic success equal
happiness the answer from the guys is a
resounding definitely even though
there's been no shortage of scenes
lately with Bateman crying and depressed
we see him lose track of the calendar
once more when scenes from President
George H.W Bush's inauguration come on
screen which Bateman thinks was earlier
in the year the inauguration took place
in January 1989 and it is now early
1991. he also says he's 27 years old
even though he's 29 now I think I'm
gonna say the same thing I got scammed
out of two years during covid they
debate the pros and cons of President
Bush and conversation eventually shifts
to work the Fisher account is no no
longer the hot commodity and now the
guys are more interested in the shepherd
account he sees someone who looks like
Marcus halberstam paying a check above
one of the doors there's a sign that
reads this is not an exit which
references the Jean-Paul sarger play in
no exits in which the characters are
trapped in a room that represents hell
Bateman may go on going through the
motions of his life and probably will
never face time for his crimes but he'll
always be crushed under the weight of
his vices however the end of American
Psycho is not the end of the Patrick
Bateman timeline so to speak and no I'm
not talking about the atrocity known as
American Psycho 2 All-American Girl
where a little girl kills him with an
ice pick and all of his crimes are
exposed no if we're going by the cannon
there were a few details about Bateman's
life documented in the American Psycho
2000 emails a viral marketing campaign
used to promote the release of the movie
adaptation of American Psycho in our
world these emails were written by the
movie marketing team not Brett Easton
Ellis however they were approved by
Elvis so some fans consider them Canon
however it is possible that these emails
are more of a sequel to the movie than
the novel because they use movie
variations of the character names like
Paul Allen instead of Paul Owen but it's
easy to chalk that up to the fact that
these emails are supposed to promote the
movie and other than that Minor Detail
the emails do better fit the timeline of
the novel because despite being set in
the spring of 2000 they fill in details
about what happened to Bateman right
after the events of the book in 1991.
plus they do make references to details
that are only in the book like Bateman's
grandfather owning a property in
Connecticut and Courtney moving to
Arizona so it's understood that this is
supposed to be a follow-up to the book
the emails describe Gene being there for
Patrick at his lowest point and by fall
of 1991 she is pregnant with their first
child even if it wasn't her initial
intention to date Patrick for his money
she does grow accustomed to being rich
pretty early on at some point they do
get married and in early to mid 1992 at
the age of 30 Patrick Bateman would
become a father
Patrick Bateman Jr would become known by
his initials PB as he grew up he quickly
learned to avoid anything that his
father would find objectionable he
preferred browsing expensive catalogs to
being entertained by the likes of Barney
or Mickey Mouse Patrick considered his
son to be his best accessory by Spring
of 1993 Gene started to not like the
idea of flying commercially she didn't
want their son to be breathing the same
air as the other flyers and this pushed
Patrick to look into purchasing a
private jet before we get to the
beginning of Patrick's email inbox he
does have two other appearances in the
novels of Brett Easton Ellis the first
is in his conspiracy satire novel
glamorama or glamorama I'm not really
sure that novel seems to take place
entirely in 1996 so five years after the
end of American Psycho and it appears
that he's still quite literally getting
away with murder the main character and
male model named Victor is planning this
big party for celebrities to celebrate
the opening of a new club like Bateman
he lives a very glamorous lifestyle as
the title would suggest one evening at a
popular bar called the Bowery bar which
is absolutely filled with A-list
celebrities Patrick is with a bunch of
publicists and the sons of a well-known
movie producer the first of his dabbling
into the movie business and he stops by
to say hi to Victor as they shake hands
Victor notices weird stains on the lapel
of his Armani suit that costs as much as
a car personally I think that's all the
evidence I need to assume that Patrick
is still up to his old ways Victor's
girlfriend finds him strange but Victor
insists that he's a nice guy I should
also mention that Victor is not the
smartest Bateman does appear in one
other Brett Easton Ella's book but it's
not really supposed to be Canon lunar
Park is a mock Memoir of the author
himself said in the late 90s and early
2000s starting with the Press tour for
the release of glamorama the reportions
where Ellis interacts with his own
characters so this most likely takes
place in the real world not the Brett
Easton Ellis Furs their little
information bits in the emails that fill
the two-year gap between glamorama and
the main events of the American Psycho
2000 emails in 1998 he left Jean and
moved to a new apartment because he felt
he needed a change he ends up in Sky
mansion in Central Park West three
floors with his own gym sauna spa and
media center he considers this time away
from Jean to be the most Pleasant time
of their relationship he also makes
getaways to a luxury hotel on the French
Riviera and teaches PB to swim dive in
water ski at the same Pavilion where he
learned each of these skills as a boy at
the beginning of the new millennium
Patrick is 38 years old and PB is seven
by this time Patrick has gotten much
richer than he was in American Psycho he
has his own private jets called the
Falcon 50 and he has all the latest in
noddy's communication technology such as
the satellite foam truly Cutting Edge he
no longer works at Pearson Pierce there
was some kind of issue and he explains
it was better for all parties involved
if he quietly laughed I'd assume he just
does investment banking on his own now
despite that he still has a new greatest
rival a billionaire from the Midwest
named Davis Ferguson he loathes Ferguson
because he has stocks in a silica mining
company that baymen would like for
himself it's Paul Owen in the Fisher
account all over again Bateman has hired
spies to keep tabs on Ferguson for the
time being Patty Winters seems to have
gone off the air but Bateman has found
other talk shows to watch he does not
like modern music the emails consist of
personal journals that seem to be to
himself and Communications with a
therapist named Dr M who has been hired
to do virtual therapy sessions he thinks
that having gone to therapy will help
him in his custody battle over his son
Bateman clearly doesn't care what the
doctor has to say about him and has
instructed him to shut up and follow
Patrick's agenda during their virtual
sessions Dr M doesn't think this will be
helpful and questions the ethics of it
but Bateman replies do you want the
money or don't you and Dr M has no
further concern the main issue in the
divorce proceedings is that Gene wants
189 thousand dollars per month in
alimony which Patrick finds ridiculous
because she grew up in a forty thousand
dollar house Patrick sends Dr M to try
to get information from Gene that could
be used in the trial as for friends and
Associates Patrick has hired Marcus
halberstam to do something overseas in
order to get away from New York after
some quote unpleasant innuendo about
Paul Owen attached itself to him
surprisingly Louis Carruthers is back
after getting divorced from Courtney
Patrick found that Carruthers was useful
at sucking valuable information out of
media and entertainment figures and
decided to make use of it price seems to
have had his own brief marriage to
Courtney and Van Patton unsuccessfully
tried to become a model there's no
mention of McDermott perhaps the biggest
surprise is that by this time Patrick
has actually gotten his act together so
it seems he indicates he stopped doing
cocaine because he sees the brand Prada
as a much better status symbol and he
claims that he has mastered his rage and
found better ways to channel his extreme
dislike of people and things but make no
mistake he may not go around killing
people anymore but he uses his cunning
personality and abundance of power to
torture and sometimes even destroy his
victims he is still in American psychic
in February PB goes to Palm Beach with
friends and comes back wanting a bigger
plane in a Horrors he's allergic to
horses but Patrick gets him a racing
horse to watch in the Kentucky Derby the
therapy sessions began on March 16th the
next day Patrick gets a call from Evelyn
apparently they're back in touch and
she's sorry to hear about the divorce
but uses it as an opportunity to take a
dig at that's what happens when you
don't marry one of your own on the 24th
he meets her for lunch at the Carlisle
hotel where she's living now he's hung
over from partying the previous nights
some things never change she shoots her
shots telling him that she hasn't had a
good time in three years Patrick isn't
surprised by this given that all of her
husbands were gay and no we don't know
how many husbands she had however she
gets upset and throws a Caesar salad at
him it crashes to the floor and when he
sees croutons he leaves telling her he
can't have them due to his diet another
major development for Bateman is that
the 1990s seem to have cured him of his
homophobia he's friends with a gay
multi-billionaire named Simone de
revenue on March 28th while aboard
Simone's 200-foot boats they plot
against Davis Ferguson and a joke about
getting an even bigger boat when it's
all over later he eats lunch with Louis
Carruthers who is now out of the closet
Patrick has been using Lewis to spy on
Ferguson's son who goes by Terry Davis
and is also gay though I'm not sure
Carruthers knows he's a spy but Bateman
is using him to get information Ferguson
was the country's largest owner of
silicon minds but the government tried
to break up his a monopoly in the 80s so
he sold the majority of the stocks to an
offshore entity secretly making his
sanitary the chief beneficiary of the
offshore company so Terry has no idea
how rich he is and Ferguson must never
let anyone find out otherwise he's going
to jail Terry is also broke now his
father stopped giving him money after
his 10th trip to rehab because of this
when he received a lunch invite from the
multi-billionaire Simone de revenue on
March 31st he accepted and Bateman
watched the entire encounter from a
nearby table Simone handed him an
envelope proving that Terry is the legal
owner of the Trey corporation which is
worth two billion dollars the next day
is April 1st the 12-year anniversary of
the beginning of American Psycho Evelyn
calls and tells him she's now being sued
by a maid who slipped on an anchovy from
the salad that she threw at Bateman he
doesn't seem too interested in talking
to her but there's a noticeable
difference in how he treats her he no
longer blows up his unwanted
relationships like he did in his 20s and
he's clearly becoming more Sly about
destroying his enemies the next day was
Sunday which is his day with PB and the
two went to the movies and saw pb's
favorites The Sixth Sense PB has
excellent taste Patrick is going to take
him in the car but the kid would rather
walk claiming he no longer wants to be
seen in the car in case he runs into his
friends PB has excellent taste it's kind
of funny how Patrick's entire life is
him flexing his wealth for others to see
and while his son is equally concerned
by what his peers think of him he
doesn't want to be seen coming out of an
expensive car I would argue that the
truly Rich are those who receive the
benefits of walking in public
transportation I guess 80s Bateman is
superior to 2000's Bateman in that
regard Patrick asks his son what they
will do if it rains even though he
clearly has a raincoat so PB brings out
some Metro tokens given to him by Gene
and Patrick doesn't know what they are
which is probably a mistake by the
writers because Patrick does use the
subway in American Psycho but we could
explain this by saying that he was so
coked up that he doesn't remember on
April 3rd Patrick seems to be falling
back into his own ways and makes this
only this time he's motivated by his
desire for a relationship with his son
to keep his mask of Sanity intact on the
fourth the shares of the Drake
Corporation are being sold to Simone de
Revenue Ferguson's name is not attached
to these shares so there's nothing he
can do about it without exposing himself
as the company's true operator and the
criminal sanctions that go with that in
a moment of desperation he calls Bateman
who agrees to meet with him at Le Cirque
in New York meanwhile Bateman has his
place photographed for architectural
digest New York issue and it's a bigger
invasion of privacy than he anticipated
one of the photographers says that
Bateman's place is almost perfect other
than the lighting fixtures which gets
under his skin the yuppies may be long
gone but he's still fixated on having
the best of the best Davis arrives on
the sixth and ends up looking foolish
when he has to borrow a jacket from the
leserk management in order to fit the
dress code Bateman also bribed the code
girl to bring him an ugly jacket just
one of the many examples of the advanced
Warfare he now employs Davis would like
Bateman to outbid Simone for the trust
shares and in exchange he's willing to
share some of the revenue from the
mining operation Bateman says he'll have
to think about it a couple days later on
April 8th after stopping at his new
favorite sandwich shop he's held up by a
beggar at the bank who asked for cash
and tries to pull a stiletto blade on it
as the man looks down at his weapon if
Bateman kicks him down and then kicks
him in the jaw breaking it he Stomps on
the man's neck repeatedly until his
trachea begins to turn pink if Bateman
really has stopped killing strangers in
this new era it seems that his Killer
Instincts have not gone away the next
day he goes out searching for the
perfect lighting fixtures for his dining
room and he comes across the building
that dorsia used to be in before a
shutdown where they are now building yet
another new exclusive restaurant on the
way back there are no cabs so he uses
one of pb's Transit tokens to hop on the
subway only it makes him claustrophobic
so he gets off early and it just happens
to come across the perfect lighting
fixtures by the stop that he gets off at
they aren't the most expensive ones but
perhaps his son has inspired him to
realize that the most expensive things
aren't always the best in the morning
abatement is woken up by a call from
Simone telling him to come over
immediately when he arrives he learns
that Davis Ferguson is dead according to
Bateman's spies around the city Ferguson
had a heart attack when his son told him
that he knew the Trey Corporation chairs
were in his name when Ferguson collapsed
through a glass table Terry ran
downstairs stairs and told the desk man
then immediately fled to Simone's
apartment in the original American
Psycho we saw Bateman follow Tim price
down the path of addiction and Obsession
in the name of becoming the most
respected Yuppie remember at the
beginning of the book he claims Tim is
the most interesting man he knows now in
the 2000 emails Arc he sees Davis
Ferguson a man richer than him and makes
the conscious choice not to go down that
path Ferguson has a damaged relationship
with his son and that ends up being his
downfall Bateman on the other hand wants
to have a relationship with PB and over
the course of these two months learn to
prioritize the father-son relationship
over his revenge on Gene at this point
he's willing to pay Gene in order to
spare PB from any more heartache but
during a lunch with a gene on April 11th
the situation changes Gene announces
that she's met someone new and that
someone is Bateman's therapist Dr Robert
n after being sent by Bateman to gather
information on her the two had fallen in
love and they were set to marry Dr M
suggests ending their sessions so that
the three of them can learn to become
friends but Bateman is overcome with
rage he breaks his wine glass in his
hand and storms out this is the closest
we've seen him to losing his temper in
the 2000 emails Arc that afternoon
detective Donald Kimball who is now the
police commissioner comes over with some
illegal cigars and wants Bateman to help
him dispose of them we don't know the
exact nature of their relationship but I
got the idea that Bateman has Kimball
under his thumb and maybe he's paid him
off to overlook certain things
commissioner Kimball notices the cut on
Bateman's hand in Bateman jokes that he
tried to kill a waiter but the ax slept
and shattered a dessert card and the two
have a laugh about it the final therapy
email between Bateman and Dr M
demonstrates how Bateman was able to
overcome his past ways and transition
from serial criminal to Puppet Master
when asked how his doctor's relationship
with Gene is going to affect him and
Bateman turns on caps lock are you out
of your goddamned mind the fact that you
are not as we speak pulling your laptop
out of your ass is a blinding testimony
to how well I have mastered my own rage
and learned to control my desire to
destroy maim and kill which would
indicate to some that you have done a
remarkable job in a rather brief time
but I think it would be safe to assume
that the professional part of our
relationship is over ironically Bateman
kind of gets what he wanted because it
is Dr M who convinces Gene that she
should not be dependent on Bateman's
alimony money in order to be happy and
with that resolved they're able to
finalize the divorce with Gene receiving
enough money to live comfortably but not
in splendor he ends the communication
with a final warning don't ever ask him
to call you Dad that name's been taken
ah Bateman cares about someone only took
38 years as for Davis Ferguson's Fortune
his estate quickly accepted the offer
that Simone made on behalf of Patrick
Bateman which I would assume it puts him
in the top 50 richest people in the USA
at least the night of the 16th Patrick
is honored at the Manhattan Children's
Center for her foundation gift that he
contributed part of the event was a
charity auction where A-list celebrities
bid on various items one of which was a
small role in a new movie called Fashion
Victims behind the scenes Patrick has
been getting into the movie business he
is applauded at the end of his speech
the next day he leaves for a vacation in
France and in his journal claims that
he's at peace with himself and with the
world he goes to the hotel on the French
Riviera the one that he went to as a kid
and brought pb2 on several occasions it
is the one place on Earth where I can
stand to be alone and in fact welcome
the opportunity to recharge rethink
regroup or just stare up into the sun
until everything becomes white and
peaceful like in heaven I don't
recommend anyone try the stare into the
sun part it's implied that this is the
coping mechanism that he's found to
recharge and it doesn't involve torture
or the end of someone's life on the
plane his Steward asks if he'd like to
watch a movie and he puts in the newest
release from one of the film companies
that Bateman has acquired it's described
as follow the film begins with the
sounds of a harp being gently plucked as
drops of red fall slowly into a sea of
white you may recognize this as the
opening of the film adaptation of
American Psycho which came out April 14
2000 three days before this plane ride
to France I would assume the in-universe
version of the movie is different from
American Psycho in our world kind of
like how the stab movies are not the
exact same as the Scream movies in this
case they probably changed the names of
people a little more than just changing
Paul Owen to Paul Allen so that nobody
would notice the similarities but then
again Bateman literally tried to confess
his crimes at one point and nobody would
believe him so who knows maybe they just
left the names the same I find it kind
of fitting that Bateman ends up
producing a movie about his adventures
remember
way back at the beginning of this video
I'm guessing that's like at least two
hours ago when I discussed Brett Easton
Ellis's inspiration for writing American
Psycho when you get into Patrick Bateman
and obviously you're not writing
autobiographically I assume Brett about
dismemberment and murder and so on but
American flag is my most
autobiographical novel can you explain
that uh that's who I was I've never come
Queen about whether I think Patrick
Bateman committed the crimes or they
were fantasies and the book is
completely open to interpretation you
may not argue it either way about it
there are clues that say it didn't
happen and he was fantasizing about this
and then there are other clues that
suggest well hey wait a minute maybe he
did do these things but in terms of
Patrick Bateman's loneliness and his
alienation from the society he was a
part of I don't think I've ever written
anything more autobiographical so Ellis
wrote American Psycho as a way to vent
his confusing feelings into the
character Patrick Bateman and now
Bateman has made an autobiographical
movie where she does the same the film
would star Christian Bale as Patrick
Bateman Reese Witherspoon as Evelyn
Williams Jared Leto as Paul Allen and
Willem Dafoe as detective Kim it looks
like Christian Bell reprized his role as
Bateman in 2005. oh oh wait no that's
Batman not bait man if he ever writes a
memoir he should definitely title it
from Bateman to Batman Patrick Bateman
is the ultimate example of what happens
when a consumer gamifies materialism the
deeper he delves into the lifestyle he
wants to portray the further his mind
becomes lost with no self-worth outside
of his money and His Image he hits Rock
Bottom when the Yuppie Trend dies out in
1991. despite blowing up all of his
relationships his secretary Gene is
there for him and together they have a
child and after getting back on his feet
and gaining control over his vices he
realizes that he does have someone he
actually cares about as I stated I do
think that some of Bateman's crimes were
real so it's not not exactly a perfect
happy ending because the killer gets
away but as the author stated it's
really up to you to decide where you
stand on the issue let me know your
thoughts on that the whole Gene versus
Jeanette thing the canonosity of the
emails and any other theories that you
have in the comments and with that we
have reached the end of this tape but
there are many other horror villain
timelines like John Kramer Michael Myers
and valik that I have analyzed just
check out that playlist on the left
remember to subscribe to cz's world for
new Horrors every week ring the death
bell and select all notifications and I
will see you in the next one assuming we
both survive now if you'll excuse me
I've gotta go return some videotapes